so auf geht's weil ich jetzt wirklich schon eine woche nicht mehr am start diese woche
gab es wenig striemser dafür gab es die woche davor in die vier stück oder sowas in dem dreh
der extreme not ist sechs monat am start a ja ja huge sap massive brain subscription
dafür gab es ein wie das stimmt habt ihr alle mein neues video gesehen
da neues video sagen gibt es oder das andere ist zwei wochen her guck mir 16
stunden zwei wochen fünf monate dann hier vor diesen fünf monaten habe ich mal richtig
viel hochgeladen da habe ich sogar da habe ich sogar relativ viele subs gekriegt die
sind jetzt natürlich schon alle wieder weg teilweise teilweise aber hier guck mal hier
habe ich hier habe ich zwei monate am stück extrem viel hochgeladen und dann wieder halbes
ja dann ja halbes ja nix wo du die nice premiere gemacht hast ja exakt die premiere ist das
ist so ein sinnloses feature irgendwie kommt mal hier kann man ja chat replay und man hat
nicht mal man hat nicht mal ordentlich im maus ich bin jetzt nicht eingeloggt ich kann mal
vielleicht sieht man sich ich benutze ab und zu mal ab und zu mal ich benutze ab und zu
mal youtube im maus und die sind so die sind so hässlich aber man kann natürlich nicht
hoch scrollen das wäre auch zu einfach wenn man hoch scrollen konnte die sind so hässlich
die youtube im maus ich weiß gar nicht was mit den los ist ich meine wenn man die sollten
doch irgendwo bei google irgendein paar leute finden die schöne emotes designen können
oder ich stelle mir das jetzt nicht so schwierig vor ehrlich gesagt ein paar leute zu finden
die es irgendwie auf die reihe kriegen also die youtube im maus sind echt hardcore hässlich
keine ahnung was mit ihnen los ist ne echt nicht
check den delfin kommentar irgendwo nicht hä du meinst bei mir ohje leute ai ai ai
ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ah
sind die italiener haben keine andere probleme als ob delfine am start sind
wahrscheinlich sind die delfine gerade wieder am start weil italien so probleme hat wie
sieht es eigentlich gerade hab schon lange nicht mehr geguckt wie sieht es eigentlich
hier so aus aktuell so schau mal die usa hat ja die haben ja aufgeholt ich habe
letzte woche geguckt da hatte die usa glaube ich ungefähr so viel wie spanien
und italien und da geht ja das ist ja komplett eine halbe million der gute
chinesen glaube ich kein wort der in chinesen glaube ich was statistik angeht
kein wort ok na gut dass wir keine neuen fälle haben ist ja ist ja klar sonntags
arbeiten ja auch die ämter nicht die sowas reporten ist logisch dass wir keine
neuen fälle haben das ist in deutschland so wenn das nicht erlaubt ist an ostern
zu arbeiten dann haben wir auch an osten keine neuen corona fälle ist logisch
bekannte von mir extrem dort schreibt bekannte von mir verteidigen das
gesundheitssystem von usa ja wahrscheinlich sind es welche in usa die
geld haben die das verteidigen und die sagen ja da ist guck mal hier zum
glück kratzen wir nicht ab ich mein man kann über unser gesundheitssystem
auch viel meckern und ich bin ja auch der meinung es wurde viel verkackt in den
letzten jahren was unser gesundheitssystem angeht was wir jetzt auch
teilweise ausbaden müssen wenn man krankenhäuser und und arztpraxen und
generell das wird das gesamte gesundheitssystem nicht darauf
ausgelegt oder nicht mehr darauf ausgelegt ist quasi den leuten zu helfen
sondern maximale kohle aus den leuten raus zu bekommen beziehungsweise halt aus
der krankenkasse raus zu bekommen für die leute dann muss man sich nicht
wundern warum manche behandlung so schlecht laufen wie sie laufen warum
manche sachen wie beispielsweise knieoperationen und solche sachen die
halt meistens gar nicht gemacht werden müssen warum die so oft gemacht werden
wie sie gemacht werden also wir haben mit sicherlich auch kein optimales
gesundheitssystem aber bei den usa die kriegen halt gerade voll auf den sack
ich war ja mit meiner mutter im krankenhaus vorher habe ich ja nachts
muss man ins krankenhaus habe ich damals auf twitter rum rum geschrieben als ich
am warteraum gesessen habe und das erste was ich gesehen habe war ich weiß nicht
mehr was es war ich glaube also war auf jeden fall in notaufnahme
irgendwas in den gerät vorerst mal wenn aus xp gebootet ist da habe ich auch
schon auch ich hoffe dass nicht am internet dran das ding
die russen kriegen auch jetzt langsam aber sicher mehr was mich ja persönlich
wundern ist dass es in afrika noch gar nicht so abgeht sagt man sagt man land
in afrika was haben wir daher süd süd südafrika
aber südafrika hat fast nix warum hat warum hat eigentlich na na asien und
europa so viel gut im nahen osten so dazwischen haben sie auch was aber
warum hatten afrika kaum was ansonsten ist das ganze solche zeug immer in
afrika am start gibt kein geld für testadum 1 was zum teufel ist diamond
princess ich habe das gefühl wenn ich nach diamond princess suche jetzt auf
google finde ich irgendwas in dieser richtung was ist diamond princess ach
das ist das kreuzfahrt schiff das ist ein eigenes land
das ist ein eigenes land wobei land oder andere
ok es ist es ist andere es ist auf jeden fall kein land
ich habe gedacht es wäre wieder in den land was einer auf seiner bauinsel
gegründet also gibt es doch gibt es noch eins oder gab es mal ich weiß nicht ob
es das noch gibt es gab mal so ein land was in das wurde aber nie anerkannt was
irgend so ein typ auf einer bauinsel gegründet hat und weil er irgendwie
gesagt hat dass es so und so so und so weit weg von der küste und so dass es
hinterzahlt also ist auf die auf die ölbohr plattform gesagt dort das ist
jetzt mein königreich sie lernt genau sie lernt war das weiß gar nicht ob es
es noch gibt genau die verkaufen jetzt adels titel weil die müssen irgendwie
geld machen die verkaufen adels titel und server hosting weil dort keiner
keiner einfach mal so hinkommt um irgendwie server zu beschlagen haben
gibt es das gibt es das überhaupt noch ja ja da ist sie lernt jetzt es ist es
sieht einladend aus zum urlaub machen oder findet ihr nicht auch das sieht
das sieht aus also diese aussicht der alte schrotter in sind das ist das sieht
so mehr aus
oder gründer ist schon gestorben
oder ok die die die die eigentlichen besitzer von sie land wohl anscheinend
exil in england irgendwo und was sich alles gibt
naja gut was auch immer ich wollte bloß mal gucken wie es aussieht wir sehen
dann wir sehen dann unsere unsere aktuellen monka monka korona fälle so
aus ja es geht ein bisschen ein bisschen lag ich
finde hier lohnt sich sogar mal auf logarithmisch umzuschalten weil dann
sieht man es besser wie das ganze abflacht
dann sieht man besser weil das ist jetzt halt immer immer das doppelte immer der
null hinten dran hier in der skala daran sieht man eigentlich dass es das der
anstieg doch ganz gut abflacht ob wir es jetzt natürlich schaffen dass es nach
unten geht da bin ich ja persönlich skeptisch weil ich war war wieder am
mein runde spazieren letztens und es gibt ja so ein paar buchten bei uns am
main und da saßen auch irgendwie was weiß ich 20 30 leute die hatten zwar alle
ein bisschen abstand aber die waren so nahe aneinander dran das das war naja
das war so der alibi abstand und sogar die polizei vorbeigefahren am main hat
sie aber absolut nicht interessiert die haben auch keinen bock da auszusteigen
woop woop ja mal gucken ich bin ich bin mal gespannt wie sich das
ganze entwickelt ich für meinen teil ich meine ich will den scheiß nicht haben
also ich habe nicht vor corona zu kriegen sage ich euch ganz ehrlich also
ich mache da alles was ich machen kann dass ich den scheiß nicht kriege auch
wenn mir wahrscheinlich nichts passiert meine chancen sind da relativ gut dass
ich das ohne großen schaden überlebe aber also wenn ich es mir aussuchen kann ja
ich wette alles machen dass ich es nicht kriege aber mal unabhängig von
der eigentlichen krankheit her oh ich muss meinen ich muss mal fragen locker
starten weil sonst sonst kriege ich die ganzen chat fragen ja gar nicht mit
was sind die richtige vm ich glaube das hier na ja so und ich muss mal gucken ob
irgendwas über sie übersehen habe subs oder fragen oder sonst wie ich frage mich
wieso das in indien nicht eigentlich machts doch gerade machts doch gerade ich
habe letztens ein video gesehen aus indien ja gut ich weiß nicht wie weit
es den glaube ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung da wurden die leute quasi mit
schlagstöcken aus der stadt vertrieben so nachdem wurde was du willst die stadt
reinfahren beim und dann sind sie alle ganz schnell wieder umgedreht die sind
da die sind da nicht so zimperlich die haben eine gewinne ich habe weniger
probleme so jetzt haben wir das fragen lock auch gestartet afrika hat keine
tests möglich das kann das kann ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen dass die dass
das gibt es keine tests ja das wäre natürlich bitter
wobei wenn die auswirkungen sieht man halt oder müsste man sehen indien auch
so wenig das ja die auswirkung muss man auf jeden fall merken so aber alles ist
über zur sache zurückzukommen also alles außer diese krankheit finde ich
persönlich nicht doch ich finde ich finde zwei sachen richtig kacke an an
dieser ganzen korona geschichte erstens die krankheit an sich also wie gesagt
ich habe nicht vor das zu kriegen zweitens das bestellen bei amazon so
langsam ist
oh ja bibi und ja ja ja excellent endlich weiß ich was ich heute abend gucken
kann er aber stellen aber bestellen bei was man pp hans immer bestellen bei
amazon ist so langsam wenn man jetzt hier zum beispiel nach elektronik
elektronik zeug guckt also gucken wir mal zum beispiel was gucken wir jetzt mal
wir gucken mal wir gucken wir nach kanada widerstände oder so elektronik
kleinkram oder so guck mal meine kanadische set
so zwanzigste obwohl es obwohl es prime auf lager ist es doch prime oder ist das
prime müsste müsste doch ist nicht prime
so das problem ist ich muss jetzt mal irgendwas nehmen was prime ist das ist
prime und es kommt 20 april also die krankheit und die versandzeit finde ich
doof aktuell an korona alles andere muss ich euch ehrlich sagen finde ich an
dieser ganzen korona geschichte zum größten teil sehr angenehm erstens dass
ich jetzt in deutschland home office war flächendeckend durchsetzt und dass
viele unternehmen jetzt infrastruktur aufbauen müssen um home office zu
ermöglichen das sind das sind zwei sachen die finde ich persönlich
natürlich super
dann als nächstes dass man jetzt na gut dass man nach dem home office direkt daheim
ist und dass die leute abstand halten finde ich persönlich toll ich habe es
ja schon gesagt ich bin eh nicht so ich mag eh nicht so viel andere leute und
begeht immer auf den sack wenn es leute gibt die kein abstand halten
es gibt ja es gibt ja es gibt ja genug leute die sind der meinung sie müssen
irgendwie ihre dominanz demonstrieren oder sie müssen irgendwie zeigen wie
krass männlich sie sind oder was auch immer mit den folgern wahrscheinlich
sind einfach nur dumm und checken es nicht und rücken immer auf die pelle so
weit dass man irgendwann einmal seinen rucksack dazwischen legen muss oder so
was das eigentlich weiter weiter auf die pelle rücken das hast du jetzt nicht in
dieser zeit das ist ganz praktisch ich finde es auch nicht schlecht dass die
leute beim becker und im supermarkt ein bisschen abstand halten auch dass die
leute mal ordentlich wenigstens auf der straße schaffen aneinander vorbei zu
laufen ohne dass es irgendwelche macht in machtspielchen ausartet wer geht jetzt
zuerst weg es gibt ja leute die haben so große
komplexe für die ist es schon quasi kompletter penisverlust im endeffekt wenn
sie die wenn sie aus dem weg gehen müssen auf der straße das heißt es
hast du teilweise echt in frankfurt leute wo ich mich frage was mit den los du
läufst über die straße drüber du gehst über die ampel gibt es über die straße
biegst links um die ecke über kommt zepra streifen da kommt ja ein typ
entgegen der ist der meinung nein er muss jetzt weil irgendwie ist sonst seine
seine männlichkeit komplett zusammen bricht der muss auf der linken seit der
muss da jetzt weiter laufen das geht nicht das geht nicht dass der auf seine
seite rüber geht da wo er eigentlich nein der muss da weiter laufen und das
haste glücklicherweise nicht jetzt ich bin ja mittlerweile schwarz schmerzlos
ich laufe einfach auch weiter mein renter zwar ab und zu mal oder man
rämpelt mal zu ab zu leute an aber es ist es ist echt ist echt
habe ich euch erzählt dass letztens ein als eine alle monika corona dass
letztens eine zu mir gesagt hat eine zu mir gesagt hat ich das ist schon ein paar
wochen her entweder sie arschloch oder du arschloch morgens beim
rolltreppe runter laufen die die war richtig die war richtig pisse ich glaube
du hast du arschloch an der rolltreppe die hat sich auch gedacht
also ich bin aus dem zug ausgestiegen und wenn man am südbahnhof jetzt kann
euch das jetzt einmal zeigen südbahnhof frankfurt wir gucken uns jetzt auf
google maps da sieht man das bestimmt wunderbar
es hat litt achten exzellent achten da sind ja fack da sind ja aber hier ne da
sind ja überall dächer drüber warum ist der google maps am südbahnhof so
warum ist warum ist google warum ist der südbahnhof so schlecht aufgelöst
das ist irgendwie ist das irgendwie top secret
ja zumindest hier hält hier hält warum ist das so schlecht aufgelöst war der
fack warum ist denn der südbahnhof so schlecht der hauptbahnhof ist mega gut
aufgelöst guckt euch das mal an hier flupp oder also auf jeden fall besser
aufgelöst nicht zumindest worauf ich raus will also wenn der zug wenn er zug
da hält dann steigt man ja hier ist die treppe irgendwie da war mal so hier ist
die rolltreppe so dann steigen die leute hier aus dem zug aus und gehen zur
treppe oder da zur treppe oder hier aus und gehen da zur treppe so und da hatten
wir eine ich bin ganz normal ausgestiegen in in der schrange gelaufen
zur treppe und die ist hier vorne an der rolltreppe ausgestiegen direkt an der
rolltreppe und war der meinung sie muss jetzt sofort auf oder von der linken
seite sie muss jetzt sofort auf die rolltreppe und die leute die jetzt da
quasi ganz normal anstehen und die rolltreppe runter laufen die müssen jetzt
stehen bleiben und quasi erst mal 20 leute kraschen lassen dass sie jetzt auf
die rolltreppe drauf kann ja ich meine ich habe die gesehen ich habe aber nix
gemacht ich bin einfach nur an meinem vordermann weiter geradeaus gelaufen und
dann ist ihr halt versucht vor mir rein zu springen ich habe nichts ich bin
wirklich einfach nur geradeaus gelaufen habe ich versucht vor mir rein zu springen
und ich bin weiter gelaufen und ist so zurück zurück getaumelt und was hier
los du scheiß arschloch fack alter was ist los ich habe da bloß gesagt ja auch
ein aufmachen und bin die treppe runter gelaufen aber es ist mit den leuten
los ich mein wer ist hier das arschloch ja die versucht rein zu springen oder ich
der einfach in der schlange weiter läuft du hast so viel gestörte leute
mittlerweile unterwegs ist der wahnsinn und das hast du aktuell nicht und das
finde ich sehr angenehm das finde ich äußerst angenehm
letztens ist mir auch einer voll in ellenbogen gelaufen bei ich sagen muss
das war ein bisschen absicht es war auch wieder so einer der der meinung ist er
muss direkt in die schlange an der rolltreppe springen ich habe den kell
schon gesehen man sieht man erkennt das man man sieht das den leuten an die aus
dem zug aussteigen und jetzt sich jetzt gleich irgendwo reintrennen man erkennt
das nämlich daran das kennt das habt ihr bestimmt auch schon gesehen
das sind leute die absichtlich nicht hingucken die die gucken beim aussteigen
gucken die wie die lage ist das ist richtig pepega style die gucken wie die
lage ist beim aussteigen und dann gucken die nicht nach links weil dann sehen sie
ja die leute die da stehen sondern gucken nur noch nach rechts so nach dem motto
ich sehe gar nicht dass da links eine schlange von 20 leuten ist und dann
laufen sie ohne nach links zu gucken einfach in diese schlange rein in der
hoffnung die leute bleiben stehen normalerweise klappt das aber ich habe
den typ schon gesehen ich habe ich wie gesagt ich habe nichts gemacht das ist
rein rein passiv wie man so schön sagt ja ich habe einfach nur so ein bisschen
weil ich den typ schon auf mich zu hab wackeln sehen habe ich einfach nur so ein
bisschen ellenbogen ausgemacht ist ein vollen bogen eingehauen
was kann ich dafür dass die leute nicht mal zwei minuten warten können bis die
die normal gesittet aussteigen darunter gegangen sind die müssen nicht
reinspringen hat er sich da hat er sich auch aufgeregt ist dann an mir an der
linken seite vorbei gedüßt hat hat hat nur böse gekockt da hat sich überlegt
ob er was sagen soll hat aber nichts gesagt die leute gehen wir voll auf
den sack ach ja tribulon genau also mein nachbar
genau mein nachbar hat mir gestern erzählt auf der straße dass korona eine
strafe gottes ist ich habe das gefühl ich habe das gefühl er wollte so ein
bisschen er wollte so ein bisschen ja so vorfühlen was ich zu dem thema sage ich
habe das aber geschickt um schifft ich habe nur gesagt ich weiß ja nicht also
und da habe ich irgendwie das thema auf was anderes auf was anderes gelenkt
weil ich echt keinen bock hatte mit dem darüber zu diskutieren ob korona eine
strafe gottes ist oder nicht das war mir zu zu lowbring keine ahnung ich weiß
ich weiß gar nicht wie man auf die idee kommt gut man muss sagen ist muslimisch
ich glaube da ist das so diese bestrafungsgeschichte wahrscheinlich
noch ein bisschen heftiger wobei wenn man sich das bei den christen anguckt so
bibel technisch da wirst ja auch laufen mit laufen mit irgendwelchen plagen
heimgesuchte sonst was da kann man sich bestimmt auch korona zusammendichten
aber der der ist feste überzeugung gewesen korona ist eine strafe gottes
ja gut weder meint der unruh schreibt hey ich suche mir einen router für mein
netz ich habe ein modem was die einwahl ins netz macht es soll keine fritte
sein da ich die dinger gar nicht mag so ist ein router wohl der mikrotik router
oder hier holt ihr den hier holt ihr den hier kostet nicht viel und dürfte
routermäßig sein das beste was du preisleistungsmäßig bekommst für 55
euro kassos leitnehmen oder ist ein bisschen teurer geworden
ja nimmste den hier den habe ich auch ich habe nicht den leit ich habe den
normalen poe du kannst aber auch den ohne poe in dem was eigentliche
unterschied zwischen dem leit und dem ich glaube es hat ein bisschen weniger
ramp kann das sein aber das dürfte preisleistungsmäßig der beste router
sein in der holen kannst du hast alles drin was ein super betriebssystem drauf
wo du wirklich alles machen kannst was du machen willst
netzwerkmäßig ist aber nichts für ist aber nichts für für noobs in dem sinn
also es hat zwar ein einrichtungsassistent der rest ist ein
bisschen komplizierter also so noob gerät ist es nicht unbedingt
du hast poe drauf du kannst das ding sogar selbst glaube ich poe poweren
das alles was du brauchst also routerpreisleistungsmäßig finde ich
gibt es nichts besseres wie wie hier den hex hex poe wie den da der ist
wirklich super und auch performance mäßig kannst du die wirklich nicht
beschweren du kannst bis zu 2 gigabit switchen und bis zu ja und 2 gigabit
routen oder halt mit fall mit ein paar firewall regeln bis zu einem bis zu
einem gigabit routen also das sollte dir für daheim ausreichen
ansonsten kann man echt kann man nur empfehlen ist ein super teil habe ich
jetzt auch schon ich habe ja meine mein selbstbau pf sens gedöhnt und alles
dadurch ersetzt top man darf ihn allerdings nicht mit der fritz box
vergleichen weil es ist wirklich es ist zwar ein router mit vielen funktionen
auch ein paar zusatzfunktionen aber es ist keine kein multifunktionsgerät wie
eine fritz box ja eine fritz box ist ja nicht nur router habe ich ja sogar mein
eigenes video zu gemacht eine fritz box ist ja noch telefonanlage
telefonanlage router router modem tv server nass was auch alles eine fritz box
noch so kann das ding hier kann nix außer halt
routen und das ziemlich gut besser als jede fritz box und auch viel mehr
funktionen als jede fritz box das einzige was du noch machen kannst du kannst so
ganz ganz extrem dreck billig nass machen mit dem usb anschluss aber das
ist noch schlechter als auf der fritz box also die dinger kann ich empfehlen
das wirklich top
hey lohnt es sich einen alten firmenrechner mit die drei auf zu kaufen
und den mit blackserver einzusetzen
kaum auf den stromverbrauch an und was auch wichtig ist also was es für den e
3s wie alt das ganze ist und ob du ob du transkoden musst also sprich in welchem
liegt deine medien schon in dem format vor dass du die an allen geräten
abspielen kannst ansonsten wenn du transkoden muss muss gucken dass du
ordentlich grafikkarte drin hast weiß ich nicht wie das damit im support in plex
aussieht ich verwende kein plex oder du brauchst eine halbwegs moderne cpu was
auch nicht verkehrt ist in cpus aber das müssten müsste der e3 wahrscheinlich
schon haben bei je nachdem wie alt er ist vielleicht auch nicht ist hardware
hardwareverschlüsselung falls du deine deine plattenverschlüsselung ist auf
jeden fall nicht verkehrt so
moin max meinung zu wählen ich habe kein betakei alles was ich bisher gesehen ich
weiß auch gar nicht ob der großartig bock drauf alles was ich bisher gesehen
haben sieht es halt aus wie ein cs mit ein bisschen overwatch habe ich ja schon
gesagt was ich persönlich gut finde ist dass es mehr css als overwatch der
grafik stil erinnert mich auf den ersten blick da muss ich mal gucken wenn
overwatch streamer das stream erst mal gucken dass es wirklich kein overwatch
ist sieht schon sieht schon täuschen ähnlich aus an manchen stellen vor allem
so die level architektur und die level texturen und wie das aufgebaut das
könnte das könnte teilweise auch echt noch über wat map sein
ansonsten ist das ein also marketing technisch machen die sehr gut bei
wähler und diese ganze künstliche knappheit mit keys und die ganzen
boosted streams und so was ist schon sehr gut clever gemacht ob der spiel jetzt
langzeit was taugt boah keine ahnung da kann ich jetzt nichts zu sagen
ich habe zumindest ein besseres gefühl über manch anderen games und meist
meistens liege ich mit sowas ja richtig wobei ich auch ab und zu schon komplett
in klo gegriffen habe mit so meinen predictions muss ich sagen also wie
gesagt bei den meisten sachen ich habe es aber enthob schon bei dem ersten
trailer gesagt dass es dass es kacke wird ich liege bei manchen sachen auch
manchmal der nebler zum beispiel bei rainbow 6 bei rainbow 6 lag ich komplett
daneben habe ich auch gesagt ey komm ubisoft verkackt das wird nix aber da
habe ich wirklich doch das einzige was man einfällt wo ich so komplett daneben
gelegen habe
qdl twitch prime fünf monate exzellenz ab ob falsches falsche mod
falsche mod fünf monate huge IQ sub
kann er 2 gigabit routen jetzt mich jetzt verarschen oder ist das
mal bald so das ernst für was willst du 2 gigabit routen ich kann aber also so
so ein anschluss dass er 2 gigabit routen muss
ja du hast wie gesagt du hast kein du hast kein wlan du hast kein modem was
nicht so was einfach nur den router aber du wolltest ja auch nur den router
haben kennst du die unify geräte ja klar ich habe ich habe ja drei stück ich
habe unify access points und ich habe den unify
nee nee ich was ich habe nur zwei unify geräte oder drei mit dem controller ich
habe die ich habe den unify controller ich habe zwei unify access points und ich
habe einen ubiquiti 10 gigabit switch das ist aber kein unify switch das in
edge switch mit command line und web interface config ist ein neues video
schon in planung also falls du es noch nicht gesehen hast ich habe nein das ist
das falsche video übrigens ich habe gestern ein video hochgeladen das da
falls du nicht erkannt hast also falls du nicht gesehen hast also da gibt gibt
ja schon neues und ich wollte mich ja immer mal über mal über boomer im
homeoffice auslassen alter was ist denn heute los das muss ich auch noch mal
machen so hat das ding ein dhcp server und dns aber also ich glaube langsam du
trolls mich echt selbstverständlich hat das das und man kriegt das auch raus in
dem man einfach mal auf die produktbeschreibung geht von router os und
sich das ganze anguckt ich sie teilweise 200k viewer er ich sie ist jemand dem
gönn ich das tatsächlich ich kann ich sie persönlich nicht mal gucken das
liegt aber nicht an ihm sondern weil ich weil das mittlerweile so übertrieben
groß ist und im chat sogar der twitch chat schon zu sehr eskaliert der twitch
chat ist nicht mehr lustig lustiges rum gemieme der chat ist einfach nur
hirnloses miem und stumpfsinn gespamme bei xqc der chat ist einfach zu groß
mittlerweile das kann ich mir nicht mehr geben der chat der fliegt der fliegt nur
noch vorbei mit irgendwelchen stupide stupide blödsinn der noch dummer ist
als sonst auf twitch ansonsten früher habe ich ich würde ich gucke ihn auch immer
also für ihn an sich gucken würde ich ihn immer noch gerne kommen den chat kann ich
immer aushalten aber das ist jemand dem gönn ich sofort die 200.000 viewer der
ist mir lieber als alle anderen mit 200.000
auf auf 2 wird flotten naja mal gucken was sie machen bisher hat es mich auch
nicht großartig überzeugt
jim neun neun monate bei der richtigen heckermans sind wieder am start
habe ich schon wieder ist egal im ort gedrückt
oh das sound ist kaputt hab das gehört
jetzt funktioniert natürlich nicht egal dankeschön neun monate huge sub ich
treffe meine eben auch nicht noch früh gab schon neue klippeinsendung ja gab ein
paar zehn stück oder so rizak sehe ich genauso er schreibt also für mich ist
auferwortsch tot hat an vielen stellen falsche entscheidungen drauf rollt
kam zu spät ja es gibt es gibt ein paar sachen die ich so nicht aber damit muss
mich nicht wieder darüber auslassen so erst mal gucken ob ich jetzt alle
bevor wir anfangen können zu gucken bevor ich alle fragen beantwortet haben wir
haben wir haben wir haben wir haben wir haben wir auch ja hatten wir auch hatten
wir auch war auch
auch gute frage
ist er neu
was ist der unterschied dazu ja ein bisschen schnellere cpu aber dies ist
nicht so dass du da irgendwie an die grenze kommen würdest also die werte
sehen es nicht gerade besser aus ah der hat hardware der hat hardware
encryption wenn du vpn machen willst oder so weiß ich nicht ob es sp ne das
brauchst du nicht du brauchst doch daheim kein sp port für was
wobei hatte hex p oe nicht auch ein sfp port
er hat auch ein sp port ok ich habe nichts gesagt weiß ich nicht ob sich der
aufpressen also wie gesagt ich habe auch den hex p oe und gibt es absolut keine
probleme mit ansonsten muss halt mal ein bisschen vergleichen gucken was du
machen willst ist jetzt ist jetzt schwierig so pochal zu sagen aber du
machst mit diesen mikrotik einsteiger und sachen wirklich nichts falsch
nutzt du p hole nee nicht mehr nachdem es nicht mehr in der lage ist twitch und
youtube ordentlich zu blocken vor allem mit twitch hat es probleme dann habe ich
da keinen keinen sinn mehr sehe ich keinen sinn mehr drin das heißt ich
brauche eine normale blocker normale blocker funktioniert ja auch prinzipiell
besser dadurch dass den content der seite erkennen kann und nicht rein über
dns funktioniert und seit dem twitch und youtube und andere seiten clever
genug sind die ganzen dns blocker zu umgehen und die dns blocker dagegen auch
nie was machen werden können ist es vorbei
tribun und sage ich frag mich wie viel kohle damit macht also eine halbe
million oder so ich jetzt auf jeden fall
jeden fall ordentlich also vielleicht nicht eine halbe million im monat aber
der wird schon ordentlich machen
so
was hast du gefrühstückt zwei brötchen eins mit käse eins mit nutella
hallo was ist denn heute los
also bist du aktuell full time im home office oder wie schaut es bei dir aus
ja bin ich aber nicht voll teil ne das stimmt nicht weil ich gesagt habe ich
bin nach wie vor arbeite ich nur vier vier tage die woche also montag
arbeite ich nicht das bringt mir diese woche wenig weil montag ist eh frei aber
ich bin ansonsten die ganzen vier tage im home office wir dürfen auch gar nicht
mehr also wir dürfen ich mein verbieten könnten sonst letztendlich nicht aber
sie haben gesagt sie wollen nicht dass die leute mit öffentlich verkehrsmittel
auf die arbeit kommt na ist das gut ich fahre kein auto dann
haufe ist und ich muss sagen es ist also die ersten zwei drei immer zum thema home office ja gibt es dafür gibt es dafür
eigentlich schöne stockfotos was home office angeht was jetzt mal irgendwie
einblenden kann nein so hipster style sehe ich nicht
im home office aus dabei ist klar also was soll ich sagen genau zum thema home office
so die ersten die ersten zwei drei tage so die erste halbe woche ich war ja erst
ab die erste woche muss ja noch wo das angelaufen ist muss ich weiß ja noch die
halbe woche auf der arbeit muss ich sagen die ersten paar tage war schon ein
bisschen schwierig auch die umgewöhnung aber mittlerweile geht es und ich muss
sagen es macht ist ich finde es mittlerweile viel besser als auf die
arbeit gehen erstens ich kann ich kann statt 5 vor 45 kann ich ungefähr bis
sagen wir mal so 7 uhr 30 pen das sind eineinhalb stunden länger das macht
riesen unterschied ich bin deutlich fitter ich bin deutlich wacher weil ich
habe sonst die wenn ich sonst wenn ich ansonsten so lange wach bleibe wenn ich
ansonsten so lange schlafen bleibe dann muss ich bis 17 oder sonst was auf der
arbeit bleiben habe ich auch kein bock drauf plus plus hin und zurückfahrt
deswegen stehe ich auch immer 5 vor 45 auf jetzt kann ich bis 7 30 pen und mach
sagen wir mal so 16 uhr ungefähr schluss weil ich spar mir ja die stunde
mit dem mit der bahn ich fahre wie gesagt ich fahre nicht eine stunde bahn aber
ich laufe ja immer noch ein kleines stück hin und zurück dass ich mich ein
bisschen bewege am tag so und also aus allein schon aus diesem
gesichtspunkt ist das ist das viel angenehmer ich muss auch sagen das
arbeiten ist deutlich effektiver ein problem was beim homeoffice machen gibt
ist allerdings die leute mieten noch mehr das hätte ich gar nicht für
möglichkeit ich habe eigentlich gedacht ok jetzt können wir was schaffen aber
die leute mieten noch mehr im homeoffice als auf der arbeit
und was war das was wollte ich jetzt noch sagen das zweite weiß ich keine
ahnung aber zum thema mieten muss ich sagen ich habe den eindruck es gibt noch
mehr meetings weil die ganzen bullshit bullshit jobs also so die ganzen
prozess koordinations bvl köppe die müssen jetzt ja irgendwie legitimieren
dass sie eine daseinsberechtigung haben und deswegen werden als noch mehr
meetings gemacht so und das das geht mir das geht mir auf den keks dass das man
noch mit die stonkstüben genau die stonkstüben dass man dass man noch mehr
meetings macht als vorher aber ansonsten muss ich sagen ist das viel
effektiver wenn man bei meinem homeoffice arbeit und man kann man kann sich drauf
verlassen und das finde ich echt cool man kann sich darauf verlassen dass die
leute anwesend sind im chat und im voice chat und in channels und so also das
heißt du kannst einfach jederzeit sagen kannst mal gucken oder hier was ist
damit oder einfach einfach mal einen anschreiben und du weißt der ist da bis
bis auf die leute die nicht da sind und da sind wir auch schon wieder am punkt
du merkst sofort beim thema homeoffice eigentlich würde man genau das
umgedrehte annehmen und wahrscheinlich viele boomer chefs nehmen auch noch das
umgedrehte am man merkt sofort wer was macht und wenn nichts macht es klingt
jetzt erst mal ja wie soll ich wie klingt es erst mal erst mal wir oder
falsch rum ja wenn ich sag dass man das mehr merkt wenn die leute im homeoffice
nicht mal mehr aber man merkt dass man kann sich wenn man wenn man im büro ist
man kann sich viel mehr hinter scheiße labern verstecken als wenn man daheim
was macht weil wenn man daheim was macht da reicht es nicht dass man ich sag
jetzt ich denke mir jetzt einfach mal aus also es gibt leute die gehen dann
fünfmal am tag zum chef und und erzählen ein bisschen was und dann hat
der chef das gefühl die machen die sind ja voll dabei voll engagiert und machen
richtig was das geht im homeoffice nicht im homeoffice kann er das zwar probieren
aber geht er seinem chef eher auf dem keks da guckt der chef nach so nach dem
watch ok was von den arbeiten die es hier gibt hat der jetzt erledigt und was
hat er erledigt und da wird irgendwann feststellen ok es gibt ein paar leute die
machen gar nix das fällt das fällt viel mehr auf im homeoffice wie wie auf der
arbeit ich bin jetzt persönlich kein fan von so was viele gerade bisschen
ältere ältere führungskräfte und auf ein bisschen vor allem deutsche
unternehmen gerne machen so dieses wir wollen viel mehr kontrollieren als als
nötig ist weil was man auch gerade sieht bei uns ist oder bei vielen im
homeoffice man sieht einfach es gibt leute die kommen richtig gut im homeoffice
klar und sind da besser als auf der arbeit und es gibt die leute die kriegen
nichts gebacken aber die kriegen meistens auf der arbeit auch nichts gebacken man
merkt es plus nicht so und bei uns ist es so was mir jetzt halt richtig auffällt
ist was mir auf der arbeit schon immer auf den keks geht wir haben leute die
sind ex die sind die sind ultra schwer von begriffen ich weiß ich weiß bis
heute nicht wie man sein geld wie man sagt keine ansage 20 jahre sein geld in
technischen im technischen bereich verdienen kann und so schwer von begriff
sein kann ich versuche ich das mal kurz zu erklären anhand einem beispiel dass
ihr alle kennt also ich gehe mal davon aus dass viele bei mir im stream ja auch
rechts technisch interessiert sind und wahrscheinlich auch schon den ein oder
anderen support fall hatten ja also so was weiß ich oma mutter freunde und
wir fragen euch so nach dem motto hier wie geht denn wie geht keine ahnung wie
geht ein drucke einrichten unter windows oder so was wobei das mittlerweile so
was ist wo ich sage ne mach dein kram alleine aber dass das kennen
wahrscheinlich die meisten so da geht ihr da hin und dann zeigt ihr das den
leuten und es läuft dann ja so nicht dass ihr das macht sondern die leute
sagen entweder zeigt mir mal wie das geht dass ich das nächste mal alleine
kann oder man denkt sich ja ich muss es den leuten mal zeigen dass sie das
hinkriegen und du stehst hinter den leuten und das heißt so jetzt ich
demonstriere euch das jetzt mal wie man sich da teilweise vorkommt wenn du den
dann sagt also jetzt geh mal hier mal auf start und drücker settings so so
sieht das dann aus was wo soll ich klicken ja unten links
was und jetzt drücker
kannst du mir das nicht machen das ist doch viel zu kompliziert so ungefähr
läuft das immer ja und das in ähnlicher art und weise ist das mit
manchen leuten auf der arbeit auch es ist unglaublich es ist unglaublich wie für
was die leute
andreitungen haben wollen ja ich habe ich habe ein eigenes video drüber
gemacht was was das ich habe ein eigenes video
drüber gemacht was ich auf der arbeit mache und eines der sachen die halt
täglich vorkommen ist code review von anderen und wenn wenn es das halt
bestanden hat die sachen die sachen mörchen und halt auch schauen dass man
nachvollziehbares change noch hat was es für neue versionen gibt so was in der
richtung ich habe es euch ja schon erzählt und es ist unglaublich wie viele
leute es nicht schaffen einen ordentlichen was immer das war einfach
keine ahnung sagt man ein schönes schönes github recht es ist unglaublich wie viele
leute es nicht schaffen einen ordentlichen mörcherequest zu machen
ich habe jetzt mal view genommen irgendwas bei uns sieht das bei weitem
nicht so ordentlich aus die schaffen das nicht die kriegen das nicht gebacken
und das sind leute die sind schon in ja am start bei uns die haben den habe ich
da schon fünfmal erklärt ich weiß nicht wie es wie es möglich ist dass man als
professioneller java entwickler in dem fall das nicht der einzige wie man das
als professioneller java entwickler nicht schaffen kann einen ordentlichen
mörcherequest aufzumachen und letztens hat er echt den vogel abgeschossener
einer bei uns der hat einen mörcherequest erstellt und ich habe
ihnen gesagt ok damit ich das nachvollziehen kann was ihr da gemacht
habt ich meine ich gucke mir zwar den quellcode an aber manchmal ist es nicht
so nicht so einfach nachvollziehbar out of context was da passiert da haben wir
uns darauf geeinigt wir schreiben in den mörcherequest rein in den titel wir
schreiben in den mörcherequest rein in den titel
den ticket falls es eins gibt also sprich fast was beauftragtes ist ein ticket und
wir schreiben eine kurze beschreibung rein also so nach dem motto
neuer button neuer button in in drucker settings irgendwie sowas ja titel und
hinten schreiben wir noch wie wie wie viel kaputt das ganze machen könnte ob
das ganze kritisch ist oder unkritisch ja also wenn jetzt einer einen button
hinzugefügt hat bei in im drucker dialog dann ist das wahrscheinlich ziemlich
unkritisch wenn jetzt allerdings einer dafür gesorgt hat dass die irgendwie
irgendwelche datenbank schemaeänderung was auch immer gemacht werden dann ist
das kritisch so dass das darf der entwickler einschätzen weil der wer
soll es uns einschätzen ich gucke es mir danach an so dass das ist das ist das
einzige was man diesen mörcherequest reinschreiben muss und halt nach
möglichkeit auch noch kommets machen die nicht fix blub und und shit geht und
und abc heißen das ist alles ich habe ja gar keine allzu großen ansprüche an
irgendwelchen neuen features und mörcherequeste hauptsache es tut was es
machen soll ja und letztens hat es wirklich einer geschafft ein wie gesagt
ein ein fulltime professioneller java entwickler hat es letzten der macht
öfter so dinger wo ich mir frage wie unfähig kann die leute sein
der hat es geschafft er hat eine mörcherequest aufgemacht also sowas hier
view ist ein scheiß beispiel für mörcherequest die sind alle so ordentlich
githab was gibt es denn für ein schönes githab projekt mit mit ordentlichen
mörcherequest irgendwie keine ahnung ich glaube hier guck mal was react hat ja
das so sieht das in der regel aus ja und der hat es geschafft eine mörcherequest
aufzumachen in dem nichts stand ich nehme jetzt einfach mal explizit also
exemplarisch diesen hier der hat es geschafft mörcherequest aufzumachen in
dem nichts stand also quasi die beschreibung war komplett leer und im
titel standen ein pipe sonst nix
komplett leer und im titel stand ein pipe habe ich schon gerade okay das geht ja geht
ja gut los da weiß der schon mal voll was sache ist was er da gemacht hat ja und
dann bin ich in die was mache ich denn hier wie guckt man sich ich bin
übrigens ich bei issues ich muss auf pull request gucken und da bin ich in die
comments reingegangen und in die in das diff und was ich da gesehen habe also
exemplarisch jetzt mal hier so ein projekt was ich da gesehen hat war der wahnsinn der
tüper hat es geschafft sachen kaputt zu machen an stellen wo er gar nichts
gemacht hat ich weiß nicht wo er das gewire das geschafft hat ja ich
wahrscheinlich hatte irgendwelche sachen von anderen leuten versucht zu
mörchen oder sonst was der chat ist sehr ruhig ja ich mache ja auch gerade cool
cool story bob time zumindest er hat er hat bei einer sache den vogel komplett
abgeschossen und zwar wisst ihr wie das aussieht wenn gibt wenn gibt einen
mörch konflikt hat das sieht ich zeige es euch mal so sieht das aus da gibt es
dann so marke in der datei wo die datei konfliktet ja also sprich wenn zwei
leute parallel miteinander an der gleichen sache arbeiten und du wollen
das dann zusammen mörchen dann gibt es dann konflikte so nach dem ok die haben
die gleiche zeile editiert der eine hat das reingeschrieben der andere hat das
reingeschrieben was ist denn jetzt das richtige so und was der gemacht hat ist
der hat einen pull request aufgemacht hatte wohl den mörch konflikt und war
zu dumm den mörch konflikt zu lösen und er hat die konflikt marker neu mit
committed normalerweise ist das so dass das geht eigentlich eigentlich geht das
gar nicht eigentlich geht das gar nicht aber das lässt mich mal wieder an der an
den skills unserer java entwickler zweifeln er hat einfach gesagt ok ich
habe den mörch konflikt was mache ich jetzt anstatt den mörch konflikt zu
lösen hat er einfach die datei noch mal neu reinkopieren mit den mörch
konflikt markern was natürlich dafür sorgt dass das
syntax mäßig komplett kaputt ist die datei und hat das committed und
eingereicht und da denke ich mir was ist mit den leuten los wie und wie ich
könnte die leute eigentlich alle sein ja das ist eine sache die merkt man
besonders im homeoffice und ich habe das gefühl ich muss bei jedem scheiß den
leuten teilweise nachrennen weil sich keiner weil sich keiner rührt und weil
sich irgendwie keiner drum kümmert da ist die frage ob er einfach keine ahnung
von git hat und oder einfach ein schlechter entwickler ist ich denke mal
beides weil gute entwickler haben ahnung von git ich weiß quick quick mass
high IQ logik ist aber so unterm strich ich glaube da ist es einfach unfähig
nikon der nähe so etwas ist das nicht ich habe ich habe mir mit packet ich
habe einen bot gebastelt der guckt ob sich das merken lässt und schreibt ein
paar kommentare rein ich habe aber kein check drinne also doch im prinzip haben
wir sowas aber ich habe da aber noch kein check eingebaut der guckt auf
mördschmarke drin sind ich bin überhaupt nicht auf die idee gekommen
dass leute auf die auf auf die glorreiche idee kommen mördschmarke
einzuchecken
aber was fertiges hängt da hinten nicht dran wie ich hatte ich habe früher was
richtig schönes gebaut oder ich hatte früher was richtig schönes schönes
gebaut da hatten wir noch ein git lab da hatte ich ein jenkins dahinter und hat
alles mögliche geprüft aber dann kam irgendwann bei uns unsere
architektur abteilung an hat mein max du kannst dein git lab kannst du nicht
weiter betreiben weil wir haben jetzt firmenweite policy wir müssen jetzt
bitbucket verwenden und in bitbucket gibt es aber auch keine plugins oder
sonst was ja wenn ihr nicht wenn es wenn ihr nicht wollt dann habt ihr schon kann
ich auch nichts dafür und jetzt habe ich mir nur einen kleinen eigenen bot
gebastelt der ein bisschen sich die mördsch request anguckt ein paar seinen
senf dazu gibt wenn es ganz so schlimm ist aber das eine mördsch
nein geht hox gehen nicht geht hox gehen nicht haben wir haben wir haben wir also
wir haben also wir haben den pre wir haben den pre receive ruck im git
drinnen der guckt zum beispiel ob syntax fehler drin sind in jammel files und
und solche sachen aber das hat der an der stelle nicht nicht gecheckt und wir
haben was noch drinnen ob der branche richtig benannt ist und solche dinge
das haben wir aber das ist unsupported weil trick 17 bitbucket unterstützt keine
git hox bitbucket unterstützt nur diese java plugin git hox also geht da
bitbucket unterstützt keine normalen git hox weil atlas in den scheiß
verkaufen will so jetzt lange noch lange noch davon davon
geschwätzt
zu wenig ist es ist fail und das ist eine sache die mir im home office echt auf
den keks geht wenn man sich um alles kümmern muss und die leute teilweise
nicht alle ja aber so extrem schwer von bekämpfen wenn du allem nachreden muss
geht mir mega auf den keks ich habe sie wie gesagt ich bin beschäftigt da jetzt
im home office als auf der arbeit ist der wahnsinn und
leute die bei allem nach wo steht das schreien geht mir auf den keks ja es ist
ja legitim zu sagen hey das ist eine kompliziertere kompliziertere aktion
ist das irgendwo beschrieben oder kann man das irgendwo nachgucken
wie gesagt ihr kennt mich ja ich bin der letzte der sagt so nach dem motto muss
das alles wissen du kannst kein gut du solltest nicht suchen müssen
man muss wissen wie man sucht das ist das wichtigste das ist eigentlich da und
oh der top skill schlechthin es gibt aber leute und das sind die die
eigentlich am meisten auf den keks gehen die wollen alles vorgekaut haben alles
obwohl sie eigentlich in der position sind dass sie es einem erklären müssten
und dann wollen sie es vorgekaut haben ja die eindeutigen wo ich euch eben
erzählt habe der ist einfach nur unfähig gewesen wahrscheinlich java zu
entwickeln beziehungsweise geht zu verwenden der andere zum den wir da auch
haben der will alles vorgekaut haben alles so nach dem motto wenn du ihm
sagst ja dann lockst du dich jetzt mal auf dem system ein und schaust mal nach
sagt er ja wo ist dokumentiert wie ich mich auf dem system ein locken
ich bin alter du bist externer war mich als was er eingestellt ist ich sag es
mal externer experte für dieses thema das ist nicht dein ernst dass du mich
fragst du nach dem motto wie komme ich jetzt auf die kiste drauf ich würde
eigentlich von dir erwarten dass du mir noch irgendwelche krassen ssh tricks
zeigst bei der kohle die du dafür bekommst in der stunde und watte
fucker wie ich wollte letztens remote mit dem was zusammen machen und ich kann
sich ja oft dings sagen ich verwende ja für alles t max also
diese hier diese terminal wo man tabs aufmachen kann terminal splitten kann und
so was so und das schöne an t max ist man kann
t max sessions joinen also sprich wenn ihr jetzt hier bei mir auf dieser vm
wert würde die einfach ich kann es euch einfach mal demonstrieren so dass ihr
jetzt ein anderer user ihr macht das t max a und sagt seid ihr auf meiner
session drauf guck ihr seht ich tippe ja was
ls na geht zurück und ihr seht hier oben ist es getippt man sieht auch dass ich
mit zwei sessions hier drauf bin das da kann man wunderbar remote über t max
auch zusammenarbeiten und ich musste dem ernsthaft letztens erklären wie wie er
sich auf meine kiste einloggt plus t max sich attached und so was wo ich mir
denke das warum warum weißt du das als externer profi nicht und dann danach
hat er danach hat er auch noch so blöd gefragt ja jetzt wurde es ja erklärt
hast das ist doch sicher das ist doch sicherlich auch irgendwo dokumentiert
ich hasse leute die fragen stellen wo sie einem quasi sachen in den mund legen
wollen kenne das es gibt leute die fragen nicht die fragen nicht irgendwie
ja muss keine ahnung muss das auf diesem system auch gemacht werden das wäre ja
ok ja muss das auf diesem system auch gemacht werden es gibt leute die fragen
dann du hast doch sicherlich die nötigen systeme schon eingetragen
ich hasse solche fragen ich krieg da übels ausschlag wenn einer mit so so
unterstellungs unter stell unter stellen fragen ankommt da da da neige ich immer
dazu bösartig antworten zu geben das geht mir echt auf den kicks und ja da
hat er danach ist er noch gefragt so nachdem ob das ist doch sicherlich
irgendwo dokumentiert habe ich gesagt ja als externer experte erwarte ich
eigentlich dass du das kannst damit hat er damit hat er nicht damit hat er
irgendwie nicht gerechnet ja ich habe danach noch gelacht weil ich mir
gedacht habe ok ich habe es eigentlich genauso böse gemeint wie wie ich es
gesagt habe aber ich habe danach noch gelacht so nach dem motto das war ja
doch nur ein witz weil ich wollte nicht ich wollte nicht den den komplett nicht
ich wollte nicht komplett versauen aber das das ging mir an dem moment echt auf
den keks erst eine halbe stunde erklärt und danach noch so dreist sein zu fragen
sagt das ist doch sicherlich irgendwo dokumentiert und selbst wenn nicht bei
einer kohle die du kriegst schreibst ihr halt auf hast du keine angst dass der
typ hier im stream zu sehen und wenn glaube ich nicht glaube ich nicht
das das blöde ist dass ich da meistens auch noch irgendwo richtig liegt ja
wie gesagt wir haben teilweise so viel unfähig externer leute die massig
viel kohle brauchen deswegen habe ich auch keine so so allzu hohe meinung von
den von den meisten konsulten typen die skipp wir haben welche jetzt muss man
natürlich jetzt auch mal sagen wir haben welche mit denen kann man wirklich super
aber es kein problem wir haben auch noch einen anderen der hat auch ewig du
merkst das schon wenn du das erste mal sich mit den leuten ein rechner stellst
und sagt ok ich zeige dir jetzt mal wo unsere git repost liegen da kannst du
das ganze klonen und ich jetzt war den tipp an euch ich zeige euch jetzt wie
man den wie man den den den den nupe admin nupe entwickler nupe def ops wie
auch immer erkennt zeige ich euch jetzt mal also falls ihr in so einer position
seid dass ihr die leuten den leuten ab zu was erklären muss so da geht da geht
er zu den sache ich zeige euch jetzt wo unsere git rebe ich zeige jetzt wo
unsere git repost liegen ich hoffe ich kann es euch jetzt überhaupt zeigen
wahrscheinlich kann ich euch gar nicht zeigen weil ich hier nicht eingeloggt
bin
ha fuck ich kann es euch nicht zeigen weil ich kann es euch beschreiben so
dann dachte ich zeige jetzt wo unsere git repost liegen kannst du dann mal
klons klon dir die einfach mal und da gucken wir uns gucken wir uns ein bisschen
da im source code um dass du das du weißt wo was zu finden ist so und wenn der
typ du sagst ihm ja du gehst jetzt auf bitbucket.bla bla bla.net irgendwas
gehst hier in gehst hier in das projekt ist hier dahin und dann klont sie dir
das du siehst sofort ob die leute ahnung haben
das erste ist wenn die eine halbe stunde den clone button suchen
da weißt du schon ok also mal sowas wie sag mal so gitlab github und
bitbucket sollten eigentlich soweit schon mal angeschaut worden sein dass man
zumindest keine fünf minuten braucht bis man den clone button findet gute leute
finden das schnell auch wenn sie das nicht kennen und das nächste ist woran
man sicher den noob erkennt ist wenn er hier auf klonen klickt und er klont mit
https da weißt du geht noob am start weil leute die damit zumindest ein
projekt mal gemacht haben wissen man klont nichts über https weil man für
jeden scheiß sein passport eingeben muss das heißt das erste was jemand macht
der nicht komplett wir im kopf ist da geht in seine account settings hinterlegt
da sein ssh key klont dann über ssh und gut ist und daran erkennst du gleich ob
jemand ein ober noob ist oder nicht aber wir hatten ja auch letztens den neuen
der hat sich genauso unfähig angestellt den kram zu klonen habe ich mir auch
schon gedacht was ist denn das wieder und drei wochen später ist er nicht mehr
da top hat ja alles wunderbar funktioniert
oh man nähe und gerade gerade das fällt mir im home office extrem extrem auf dass
man sich um so viel um so viele sachen kümmern muss und auch so viele sachen die
andere machen achten muss es ist der wahnsinn und ich habe sie ich habe sie
im letzten stream ja schon gesagt ich habe sie im letzten stream schon gesagt
man merkt sofort wer mit wem man gut zusammenarbeiten kann online und das
sind leute und ich wie gesagt ich will mich jetzt nicht nur drei mal drei
stunden wiederholen weil ich habe es im letzten stream schon gesagt übrigens
dankeschön für den sub b 29 korn acht monate in folge huge sub habe ich noch
irgendwas übersehen
hochscrollen no happy meet for you auch neun monat dankeschön
richtige high IQ subs leute shingel kuro neun monate heute geht es aber ab
dankeschön für die ganzen subs ich war so am erzählen ich habe es gar nicht gar
nicht mitgekriegt you jim den hatten wir schon trotzdem auch noch mal
dankeschön nice subs ja und wie gesagt ich will mich jetzt nicht drei stunden
wiederholen weil ich habe sie im letzten stream schon gesagt du merkst sofort wenn
leute erfahrungen haben online mit leuten zusammenzuarbeiten was home
office angeht reptile hunter sechs monate richtiger master hacks war am
start und da gleich ist auch zwei monaten schon jetzt der hype train auch
am start jetzt jetzt fährt der hype train du hast nur wenig zeit um
exklusive emotes zu verdienen leute morgen gibt es nichts mehr hyperklep
jetzt auch mit den satz noch 50 50 dass ich die dass ich noch 50 mal anfangen
muss um jetzt nicht wieder drei stunden zu wiederholen man merkt wer gewohnt ist
um online mit anderen leuten zielführend zusammenzuarbeiten und leute
die online competitive games gespielt haben die online progress mmos gespielt
haben sei es pvp sei es irgendwelche rates in in 5 6 7 8 40 mann leuten die
wissen wie man online zusammenarbeitet
der wahre pro im home office ist derjenige der gut online spielt der
competitive bzw progress online spiele gespielt hat das ist der wahre
homeoffice pro weil der geht ab mit dem verstehst du sofort was gemeint ist da
weiß wie man online mit leuten reden muss da weiß wie man so online mit
leuten redet dass die verstehen was er meint und er selbst mitkriegt was die
anderen machen
ja online spieler sind die homeoffice pros ist einfach so und man merkt das der
unterschied ist so krass zwischen leuten ich kenne ja die meisten die ja da sind
kenne ich ja schon länger ich weiß was sie früher gemacht haben und die leute
die oder felix zum beispiel den kenne ich vielleicht aus meinen videos von
früher mit dem war ich auf der games kommen wir haben wir haben drei vier
videos zusammen gemacht ist auch mit dem wo ich das video aufnehmen wollte bei
uns aus dem rechenzentrum was ich bis heute nicht geschnitten habe
der erste gleich die online spiele gespielt
wir haben noch ein paar andere leute mit denen kannst du auch super online
zusammenarbeiten du merkst sofort die haben online spiele gespielt die
blicken einfach durch wie man online zielführend mit anderen leuten
zusammenarbeitet ja meinem chef merkst du auch an der hat
battlefield und andere online spiele gespielt das merkst du mit dem kannst
du einfach ganz normal online kommunizieren und da weiß wie das
funktioniert auf der gegenseite hast du dann so leute die in den instant
messenger schreiben sehr geehrten guten morgen sehr geehrte kollegen das
monitoring meldet heute wieder fehler bitte kümmern sie sich um eine
schnellstmögliche was weiß ich blabla blabla mit freundlichen grüßen ihr
monitoring team was ist mit euch los das ist ein instant messenger schreib rein
server a tut nicht mehr und gut ist du musst du musst da keine roman
reinschreiben schreib einfach rein so nach dem motto
motto server xy ist die festplatte voll guckt mal einer das ist online
vollkommen ok kann man machen muss da kein roman reinschreiben aber ihr
kennt bestimmt leute die schreiben auch in sms und sowas also die schreiben ja
auch noch sms schreibt ihnen immer mit freundlichen grüßen und sowas da
merkst du dass es so die wahre wahre war boomer obwohl die teilweise gar nicht
mehr so alt sind ja und gerade leute die online spielerfahrung haben mit denen
ist das ist das so angenehm zusammen zu arbeiten im home office und das
funktioniert auch so gut das funktioniert auch gut letztens mit
einem zusammengeguckt bei dem weiß ich auch da hat früher zs gespielt und
mmos halt in festen teams und hat auch bisschen progress relates gemacht
der weiß wie man online mit anderen zusammenarbeitet letztens angerufen
im teams erstens ein ordentliches headset hat am start gehabt und nicht
dieses open mic vom iphone was was viele online noobs am start haben
wo es dann rauchte wurde die kinder im hintergrund schreien hörst und sonst
was er hat erst ein ordentliches headset am start gab ich ihn angerufen im teams
er hat auch immer zwischendurch wenn nichts war hat er sich gemutet also
quasi so art push to talk gemacht wo du auch schon gleich weißt ok endlich mal
einer da weiß was sache ist da haben wir uns zusammen angeguckt sind wir
zusammen bei team max in die gleiche session haben uns seinen branchen kit
angeguckt haben bisschen kommets umgeschrieben und dann haben wir uns
haben wir noch ein bisschen zehn minuten blödes zeug gelabert und dann war
fertig und es hat alles funktioniert und super wunderbar du ich sagst euch wenn
es home office angeht online spieler sind die neuen home office bros ist so es
arbeitet keiner besser im home office als erfahrene online spieler die wissen
einfach multiplayer online spieler die wissen einfach wie es geht
kannst du bitte zeigen welche filter du bei obs aufs mitgemacht hast ja wo ist
es denn kompressor und ein bisschen lauter gemacht das war es anderen kram
habe ich raus so habe ich die habe ich die sub schon vorgelesen wenn haben wir
denn hier dark light reptile hunter ich glaube ich hatte schon aber trotzdem
dankeschön für die subs max du hast im letzten livestream gesagt dass bei dir
auf der arbeit leute als quer einsteigen angefangen ja benutzt was oder wie
sollte ein qe anfangen durch judymi kurse oder würdest du was anders ist qe
qualitätssicherung oder was du meinst was meinst du kann ich wenig zu sagen
du bist ja echt am rost ja ich habe mich jetzt gar ein bisschen darüber
aufgeregt da muss ja auch mal sein ne aber wie gesagt pflanze 400 der guckt
garantiert nicht im stream zu und selbst wenn ich sage ja keine namen und man
muss sich ja mal irgendwo ein bisschen auslassen können
ich habe auch kein problem mit wenn die sich nicht über mich aufregen oder so
sollen sie mal machen
so ich glaube ich habe nichts über sehen positiv sehen wenn die java
entwickler kompetent wären dann wäre dein job überflüssig
näher das ein haben im anderen gar nichts zu tun ich ich programmier kann java aber ich
erwarte von java programmierer dass er ordentliches java programmiert und dass
er auch weiß wie man das eincheckt
moin max hat mich gestern über den battlefield video gefreut das ist sehr
nice scheint es ist gut angekommen das freut mich er hat auch bock gemacht das
video mal wieder aufzunehmen
java oder java
hä du meinst java oder java dann eindeutig java java das ist noch
schlimmer ist die kombination javascript javascript unter jubantu
gibt es ein anbieter von video konferenzen in dsg vo einhält kein schimmer
fragt sich den falschen was so was angeht schon gesehen dass twitch die ganzen
regeln verschärft hat und die ganzen titty streamerinnen jetzt body painting
und tanzen machen ja habe ich gesehen twitch hat mich sogar zu einem webinar
eingeladen was nacktheitsrichtlinien angeht stand auf deutsch drinnen
wo bloß nehmen sie jetzt am webinar nacktheitsrichtlinien teil stand
drinnen so ich weiß nicht ob das so gute idee ist
pflanze 400 fragt weißt du ob ich die fritzbox 7590 auch weiterhin unser chat
weiter gescrollt weiterhin nutzen kann wenn ich einen eing anschluss nutzen
möchte
keine ahnung müsste ich nachgucken was sie für ein interface hat
die ladenverbindung juckt mich nicht was ist denn hier der abluster
bis wie viel ja ja anscheinend schon
moment die hatten kabel modem ne oder anschluss an ein kabel modem ach so rum
bitte mehr solche facepalm story da kann ich jetzt ein ganzes stream
erzählen ach qe ist quer einsteiger ich habe
das ist quality insurance oder sowas ok dann was war noch mal die frage dann
habe ich jetzt verkackt mit was man am besten anfangen sollte als quer
einsteiger judy mir kurse boah das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen weil ich bin ja
nicht quer einsteiger im eigentlichen sinne also ich meine ich habe ja schon
was gelernt in dieser richtung und bin da so mehr oder weniger reingewachsen
das ganze ich habe noch eben ich habe im leben noch kein judy mir kurs gemacht
ich habe ein paar reviews gelesen dass die dinger ganz ok sind aber ich glaube
die frage wird sich wahrscheinlich so gar nicht gar nicht stellen weil wenn du
schwer einsteigen wenn du quer einsteiger bist da ist es ja wahrscheinlich ein
gebiet was dich interessiert und in dem du eh schon gut bist
ansonsten wird schwierig quer quer zu einsteigen hat sich auch nee nee nee
bitte please nicht wieder leck nicht wieder leck
judy media
jetzt schon wieder
erscheint scheinlich mehr nicht zu lecken ok alles gut
wie die fv habe ich auf einmal 300 zuschauer ja schön dass ihr alle dabei
seid leute haben jetzt gerade wirklich 300 leute zu gehört wie ich über das
homeoffice über die manche leute wie sie wie sie unfähig sind sachen im homeoffice
zu machen auf der arbeit gerettet habe ja krass krassen hexa am start hier mit 300
leuten oder habe ich in den host verpasst kann das sein
ja also pflanze 400 so wie ich das lesen würde kannst du mit dieser fritz box
auch gigabit warnen was gegen gigabit internet gedöns machen also ich mein
wenn das hier bei vm steht für eine 7590 dann wird das auch für deine 7590
gelten es sei denn da muss man da muss man immer
jetzt habe ich noch 240 easy twitch eine sache muss man drauf achten es sei denn
du hast so eine abgespeckte provider 700 77590 das gibt es ja auch es gibt ja
manche provider die eins und eins hatten so was glaube ich die so eine so eine
so eine eigene provider abgespeckte fritz box haben da muss man dann ein
bisschen gucken ob das damit funktioniert aber in der regel schon
ein youtube video von jenna zahm einer teilmutter ist mir fast der art weggeblieben
aber es war richtig erfrischend das ist sehr schön sehr nice
dankeschön für den sub drei monate flex press
fix fliegex ach du fliegexpress okay jam folie skills so ok ich habe jetzt so
lange geschwätzt leute ich habe jetzt schon eine stunde 15 minuten geschwätzt
wir gucken wir gucken jetzt mal ein paar videos mit echt zeit
schnell gucken ob ich alle fragen durch hab die hier offen geblieben sind hatten
war hatten war hatten war hatten war ja tribulon das ist ein guter das ein
guter punkt ich könnte mir vorstellen dass die ganze corona geschichte
zwangsläufig dazu führt dass viele firmen feststellen also dass ich erst
mal viele firmen zwangsweise wenn sie überleben wollen um infrastrukturen
möglichkeiten von von home office und anderen sachen kümmern müssen
ich meine es gibt ja firmen die sagen noch nicht die sagen nicht home office
oder oder sonst was sie sagen noch telearbeit da merkste echt wo die
bu- also da ist wirklich ist alles verloren eigentlich die schicken
wahrscheinlich auch noch faxen und ich glaube das könnte dazu führen dass in
zukunft home office deutlich mehr akzeptiert ist das habe ich hatten wir
uns hatten wir gerade weiß ich nicht nice jo ich finde schon dass ich das
video gefallen hat java entwickler hatten war ja hatten wir auch hatten war
ja ich bin da facecam streamer schlechthin
warum ist das jetzt nicht drinne die frage oder habe ich das gerade weg
geklickt
das kann weg geklickt die stadt ich starte mein mein mein bort neu also dann
gucken wir mal ein paar videos so viel zum thema home office an so an sich
zusammenfassen kann ich aber sagen ist eigentlich super geschichte ja top man
ist effektiver und man muss was mir halt ein bisschen auf dem keks gibt es
manche leute und wie gesagt ich mache home office mehr als auf der arbeit
lern docker right now
schaust du ihnen ein e-sport ja ich gucke öfters zs es ist für mich zum
zuschauen der beste e-sport überhaupt das gucken wir jetzt was gucken wir jetzt
was gucken wir jetzt weiter pilot reacts to battlefield 3
dings hier flugzeug mission das müssen wir uns angucken
musik ausmachen dass das das muss uns angucken da bin ich mal gespannt
ach der typ den kenne ich das ist sogar sein channel ich dachte es ist so ein
so ein reaction channel von dem habe ich schon ein paar sachen geguckt der zum
beispiel auch mal gezeigt wie man wie ein echter pilot im flugsimulator
klarkommt mit home setup und so was react auf ein react video ja exzellent
das ist next level react mit welchen kommentatoren und früher hast du noch
kein hast du noch kontakt mit gar kein mehr ich hatte mal eine zeit lang noch
mit dem kram boom kontakt das lag aber auch daran dass ich jetzt dass ich
irgendwie so so menschenfeindlich wie ich bin dann auch immer so lahm
geantwortet hat hat er wahrscheinlich kein bock mehr auf mich das kann ich kann
ich auch nachvollziehen ja was so zwischenmenschliche aktionen angeht bin
ich halt sehr lo lo skill jetzt kein bock mehr und ansonsten eigentlich mit
keinem mehr
ihr habt in der berufsschule beigebracht bekommen wir an fax
funktioniert nice dass damit kann sie bestimmt mal was anfangen
wobei wir können auch anfangen mit cobalt in 100 sekunden was haltet ihr
davon mit was man einfach cobalt in 100 sekunden oder wir können uns in
fighter pilot an der reaktion nach gucken wir uns cobalt an hast du noch
kontakt mit ins korb nein schon ewig nicht mehr unsere unsere channelsachen
und und interessen sind ja auch schon ziemlich an ziemlich
entgegengesetzte richtung abgebogen
was ist das für einen tick überall 1 rein zu schreiben aus rufe zeichen 1 da
habe ich das erklärt
schaust du er ja genau zu dieser geschichte schaust du irgendwie noch ein
e-sport wollte ich auch sagen ich gucke eigentlich überall mal ein bisschen
ja also ich gucke einmal auf twitch was so rum ist was so läuft ich gucke ich
gucke sogar manchmal auch hier auf der storm und starcraft 2 aber hauptsächlich
in letzter zeit gucke ich eigentlich zs zs ist das coole man muss es nicht
spielen gut ist bei allen e-sport so das weiß weil es bescheuert zählt jetzt
nicht wirklich aber zs ist super ist ist einfach das beste zum zugucken
zs ist gerade schnell genug dass es nicht langsamer dass es nicht langweilig
wird und und langsam genug zum größten teil dass es zuschauen auch dass du
genau nachverfolgen kann es passiert du merkst dass du vollkaster als observer
schon lange erfahrung in dem game drin haben und auch so der production value
von den von den zs streams und was ist immer ziemlich gut das ganze wird nur
noch getoppt durch koreanische koreanische starcraft stream sowas die
also die muss man sich aber original angucken ja aber das hält nicht lange
aus aber koreanische starcraft auch koreanische loll streams oder sowas die
sind die sind die sind einfach geil weil die immer so ultra ausflippen die die
koreanischen kommentatoren sind einfach gar die ganze zeit immer am
eskalieren weiß ich auch schon mal koreanische
streams geguckt haben die die flippen immer komplett aus und schreien dann
darum
das ist teilweise ganz los ja ansonsten ernsthaft gucken wo mich auch das spiel
interessiert gucke ich eigentlich zum größten teil
die letzte zeit nur noch zs auf erwarscht ist ja gerade nicht na auf erwarscht
seitdem auf erwarscht auf youtube ist gucke ich da ich habe nicht ein match
mehr geguckt seit auf erwarscht auf youtube ist und die haben jetzt ja auch
keine matches mehr seit corona okay also gucken wir uns mal den fighter
pilot an der reacted kann sein dass ich ein bisschen lauter machen muss ich
erstmal erstmal ausprobieren wie die lautstärke ist
passt doch eigentlich oder ist okay oder oder ein ticken lauter
what's up everybody ticken lauter vielleicht ein bisschen bisschen zu
extension of the mover mailbag today got an email from a whiz oh and it says
hey mover i've enjoyed watching your videos and particularly like the mover
ruins movies videos you do currently a strike eagle was awaiting b course start
b course is the basic course so once you finish iff you go to the b course
yes just military galama canado yes i know you're feeling about was i think
they're fine as people i just however there's a mission in the game battlefield
3 i believe where you are an f18 whiz oh and goes through some dog fighting and i
think a mover ruins movies type video for that would be kind of entertaining to
watch obviously it's a video game from 2011 but i find it quite fun to hear
someone with more experience than me break stuff down oh by the way when
going through i ff optisch finde ich die battlefield 3 mission bis heute immer
noch eines der besten battlefield mission aber ich glaube mal dass sie
absolut unrealistischer bullshit ist f16 pilot seem to need the most prompts
but i digress a little bit of trash talking from the student whiz oh awesome
you know why because f16 pilots are single-seat he's probably confused of
why you're talking in the back usually our incentive riders don't say a whole
lot anyway i digress let's take a look i pulled up the battlefield 3 jet mission
with ultra graphics on the youtube and we'll break it down and see how it
works out so here we go
mit ff was jetzt ach das ist halt intro alter übertreibt man nicht
and alright so al-bashir in the pilar sees power in iran almost the same day
as the earthquake they became a threat play hockens we just got raised to
alert one plans have changed we're launching now okay there's no such
thing as alert one get wrecked first off so we are lieutenant jennifer kohl of
the hawkins a whiz oh on the george was zum teufel ist ein whiz oh ich habe kein
schimmer ich was ist das ah ein weapon systems officer also die
tippen die hinten drinne sitzen und dinger machen
wieso steuer software genau ganz genau wieso steuer software wieso sparbuch ein
waffenoffizier a verstehe bush in die persian golf
and maybe a factor later cag says we're special today we're snowflakes on station
for some delta ground support okay whiskey delta weak dick i think it's
probably what he means i've never battlefield loves to say these whiskey
delta just weak dick and yes junior enlisted folks will get out of the way
of officers in the peeways here but they don't salute especially without a hat
or a cover if you will for you maybe folks
okay eland is electronic intelligence it's signals it's not you know satellite
images do not come from eland this is just a jibber jabber acronym that they
found and and wrong about but and also we don't do the briefing walking out to
the airplane usually they're in a briefing room prior to the mission
jetzt jetzt wo er sagt das habe ich das hat mich bei der bei der mission auch ein
bisschen gewundert dass du quasi an dein auftrag von deinem pilot quasi auf
dem weg zum flugzeug erzählt kriegst so nach dem motto auf auf aufstehen wir
haben eine mission und direkt ins flugzeug also ich dann würden
wahrscheinlich deutlich mehr im wasser landen wenn das wirklich so wäre
so at this point there what's called walking in the air force is stepping and
they wouldn't be briefing the classified mission just walking down the hallway
fangs out fangs out so real thing oh she's staring at his ass stop sexually harassing him i think that harness is wrong
now that's pretty much if there's a rainy bogeys in the air already it's a weird we're harness
oh yeah so my buddy gb we're talking about this he pointed out that yes this is
6 monat lang schüttes ab also so gar nicht lustig er
when you're walking out there so they wouldn't be just carrying it and they
wouldn't have where's his helmet bag where's his pubs kit where's all the
stuff he needs to go do this mission and she's staring at his ass again yeah this
harness is wrong in the navy used to drive me nuts in the navy the harness
okay er weiß echt wovon er redet da gibt's nicht viel auf jute in dem fall
weiß er wohl wirklich sehr genau von der rede da klippy clips here so you always
wear it so his harness is attached to nothing and his legs aren't in it so if
he jacks there's nothing really gonna happen here he's gonna fall through it
because his legs aren't attached to anything you don't have the little crotch
erst mal schleudersitz und durch fall dort und hock them back to the back so it's
okay this looks like some hybrid thing without the clips so there's really
oh nice so you've got a hornet on the cat in afterburner with no one in it
carrying looks like name seven and an aim nine so it's got a two by two loadout
with three fuel tanks das werden im leben nicht aufgefallen der mission aber
schon ziemlich bescheuert oder warum warum haben die das ding überhaupt an wenn
keiner drinnen ist bombs sieht cooler aus
benzinverschwendung ja das ist ja richtig kokos das ist ja richtig kokos
so the mask is clipped to your harness not on the helmet that's an airforce
sounds like she's wearing her mask okay this is funny a lieutenant hawkins her
call signs wedge they really didn't like this check because wedge is kind of a
demeaning call sign for the simple is plus two is is is is wedge so dass ich
kartoffelecken dachte kartoffelecken heißen wedges wedges oder wedges
okay kartoffelecken alles klar also fliegt mit lieutenant kartoffelecke was
es leckt or please unity media nicht wieder leggen
es leckt überhaupt nicht das leckt und die media please
komm on ich leggen unity media auf zu leggen stopp die night leggen ist nicht
erlaubt okay das leckt auch nicht mal das war einfach mal sagen was sache ist
okay that's the only very few hornets have the stick in the back the super
hornet i think they're only at the rag so lemore at this point maybe oceania
usually they have their little hand controllers on the side but no stick in
the middle i don't think you'd be deployed with one that actually has the
stick installed they wouldn't stelle so sie mona dankeschön
yeah no stick for you you do that you're the pilot
ja er muss es wissen
my buddy gv ist er nicht sogar ist er nicht sogar f-35 pilot gewesen ich habe
ein video von ihm geguckt wo man seinen letzten flug gesehen hat ich glaube er
ist f-35 f-16 pilot mal gewesen oder f-18 f 16 ok ok dann weiß er besonders
gut wovon er redet he says also and this is from hornet vids so if you want to
check out his chance m1 brau zwei monate dankeschön für den zapp
i'll go subscribe i'll leave the link but second in line they don't tell you
what you're where you are it's just pretty much you know because they've
already briefed all this stuff
nope
so you wouldn't do this because number one they do have a plane captain to do
like left right up down all that stuff but that's the pilot checking that and
he's checking it against the fcs and if he needs the look he can just turn
around it's not that far for him to turn around and look he wouldn't need
hawkins to be doing all of them father message so überlegt na es ist
eigentlich total bescheuert wenn derjenige hinten der gar kein gar keine
möglichkeit hat das flugzeug zu fliegen checkt ob die elektronik und sachen die
nötig sind um das flugzeug zu fliegen funktionieren weil die soll er das
checken wenn er gar nicht die controls für hat und wichtig ist dass das doch
vorne ist vorne beim pilot funktioniert das ist fürs gameplay klar aber
trotzdem hat man bestimmt auch anders sein können
at this point and was oh what are you like them or not aside they are just
passengers they're not doing any of this stuff for you
der pilot sitzt hinten der pilot sitzt hinten wäre ziemlich beknackt oder das
ist aber obnichs one button i don't know what stroke means but that's not a thing
the cannon and there's no it doesn't it doesn't school up or anything on the ground like that
you don't have any nine axes every act they could arm the flares or items also
eins muss bei dem game echt lassen der sound von battlefield 3 ist richtig geil
gemacht
okay good ends good highs good lows no outline is gibberish none of that makes
any sense good hides as in hydraulics this might come from the speed angels
video where they the pilot wipes out the flight controls and the tomcats and she
says she had good hides what kummer ist ein echtes pilot pilot in speech she's
calculated it but aber das wird so viel kokona ich habe keine ahnung was es geht
seems as exactly what it doesn't listen on the
american twenty fifty lyme centre in the persiam gulf
Sie hören zu Miami Center.
Und es gibt einen amerikanischen
2050 fliegt
in den persischen Golf.
Wahrscheinlich nicht großartig.
Okay, der hier hat gerade geschmolzen.
Auch das, wahrscheinlich.
Hier wir gehen.
G.B. sagt, du würdest die richtige
Runde machen, aber du könntest, wenn du
auf einem Scrambler ein Alertfighter bist,
also lassen wir das gehen.
Gute Geschwindigkeit, gute Autos. Ich meine,
das ist ein bisschen zu langsam.
Sagen, wie du kopierst, ist das größte...
Ich würde nicht sagen, wie du kopierst.
Keiner sagt das, unless du wirklich
nicht kopierst.
Das ist ein bisschen schmutzig zu sagen.
Ja, sie machen einen 180. Du würdest
nicht einen 180 zurück zu dem Boot machen.
Wer ist der Fluchtführer?
Normalerweise reint ihr auf
den Fluchtführer. Der Fluchtführer reint nicht auf dich.
Okay, also sie bekommen einen Vektor,
um sich zu interessieren.
Angels 3 ist 3000 Füße.
Master Armand, gute Lichtung. Okay.
Er ist sehr weit vorwärts,
als wäre er der Fluchtführer.
Oder ist er der Leiter?
Er ist einfach schrecklich.
Im Fluchtführer wird es schwer
aufzuhängen, besonders mit drei
Bagger.
Er hat sich nie um Miner-Turbulenzen
interessiert.
Oder irgendeine Miner-Turbulenz in einem
Fluchtführer.
Hier geht's los.
Jetzt machen wir was.
Wer ist Shark 42? Wir oder sie?
Das ist kein Ton.
Sie schießen dich in den Gesicht.
Schreckliche Intercept.
Sie sind jetzt hostile.
Bring ihn zurück und Fox 2.
Sie sind hostile.
Der guckt richtig, als tut sie weh.
Okay, weißt du, warum er das gemacht hat?
Weil du einfach gefahren warst und ihn nicht geschossen hast.
Du warst...
Schrecklich.
Er hat eine hohe Geschwindigkeit.
Er ist auf meiner 6.
Du hast gerade gesagt, dass er auf deiner 6 ist.
Und jetzt weißt du nicht, wo er ist?
Okay, wenn der Whizzo zurücksehen kann,
so wie das.
Egal ob sie einen Exorcist brauchen oder
sie ist wirklich flexibel.
Er macht die Affärde, Schaller.
Sie ist die Kartoffel-Ecke.
Fox 2.
Der Whizzo schießt nicht.
Er sollte im Vordergrund sein.
Doctriniert ist der Pilot,
der sie schießt.
Er schießt nicht.
Er sollte im Vordergrund sein.
Doctriniert ist der Pilot,
der sie schießt.
Er schießt nicht.
Doctriniert ist der Pilot,
der sie schießt.
Er schießt nicht.
Er fliegt,
das Gewehr schießt,
die Raketen schießt.
Wenn der Pilot alles macht,
wofür ist der Typ eigentlich da hinten?
Was macht der denn eigentlich?
Navigieren.
Oh Mann.
Da ist er.
Er hat sich wieder im Gesicht geschossen.
Oh oh.
Keine Freude.
Und warum fliegt sie?
Sie hat keine Ahnung, was passiert.
Typisch.
Oh oh.
Dann schieße sie.
Nein, brechen.
Schieße sie.
Fox 2 sagt, es ist nur Fox 2.
Du sagst nicht Cent.
Das ist dein Job, Kumpel.
Oh oh.
Und während du schiebst,
hattest du einen Job.
Du hättest sechs checken müssen.
Oh oh.
Du musst brechen.
Flare.
Jink.
Dieser Typ ist schrecklich.
Was meint er mit Jink?
Er ist schrecklich wie ein großer Hund.
Dann schießen sie schon die beiden AIM-9s?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Der Hornet ist auf zwei Grad hoch.
Und das ist es.
Das ist ein Helmet.
Es ist nicht wie ein 50er aus dem Fenster oder was auch immer.
Wenn du nicht im Flugzeug in Regen bist,
dann schiebst du nichts.
Das ist dumm.
Und der Wizz ist nicht schießen.
Oh nein.
Sie, was machst du?
Was?
Es ist nur ein Videogame.
Du wirst dich zu wütend über das.
Wow, das ist eine tolle Waffe.
30 Grad aus dem Vorsicht.
45 Grad aus dem Vorsicht.
Schau dir das an.
Von der Backseite.
Sie schießen nichts.
Vielleicht ist das realistisch.
Wenn du nur Missile hättest,
die du benutzen könntest.
Vielleicht ein AIM-9X.
Und dann kannst du dich auf die Klappe fassen.
Die Klappe ist nass.
Und dann kannst du auf die Klappe fassen.
Wo kommen die ganzen Raketen her?
Die eine Arbeit, die du hattest.
Break, Jank, break.
Das Typ war nervös.
Warum jankt er?
Er ist so smart in der Kontrollzone,
dass er nur Aileron-Rolls macht.
While he waits for you to put the reaper around.
Oh!
Uh-oh!
We got hit!
Just...
There you go, Whizzo! Arm the seat! You're the last flair!
Das ist echt geil!
Oh, and you're using the high-off-boresight gun.
Das muss ein neuer Vorteil der Hornet sein.
Das ist nur schmerzhaft.
Oh mein Gott.
Boom!
Gut geschossen, gut getötet.
Alles klar, ich hatte genug.
Okay, ich bin mir sicher, wenn etwas anderes passiert, denken sie, dass sie Bomben fallen und so weiter. Aber egal, das ist genug.
Es ist nur ein Videospiel. Nehmt es nicht zu ernst.
Ich glaube, ich habe viele Kommentare gesehen, in denen die Leute gesagt haben, ich will Whizzo sein.
Und es ist nichts falsch, ein Whizzo zu sein. Ich würde einfach...
Ich würde mich auf einen Piloten auswählen.
Weil Piloten sind die, die schießen, fliegen, alles machen.
Ich hasse keine Whizzos. Ich habe nur nie...
Sie sagen, ein Single-Seat-Fighter-Pilot ist nie in einer Situation, in der er so ist, man, ich wünsche mir einen Whizzo.
Ich würde gerne 800 lb.Fuhr auswählen, damit ich jemanden im Backseat haben könnte.
Strike Eagle Bubbles lieben sie.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass die Super Hornet-Leute vielleicht 50-50 sind.
Aber in einem Single-Seat-Fighter habe ich noch nie jemanden benutzt.
Nicht zu sagen, dass sie schlechte Leute sind. Ich habe nur nie jemanden benötigt.
Das sagt, dass es ein Video-Game ist. Ich glaube, dass ich nichts Realistisches gefunden habe.
Das ist nur so, wie es ist. Aber es ist für Unterhaltung.
Ich habe dieses Spiel vorhin gespielt, als es kam.
Und ich war auf dem F-16 fliegen und habe es genossen.
Minus das, dass man als Fahrer fahren muss.
Ich glaube, es wäre cooler gewesen, wenn man fliegen könnte.
Aber ich verstehe, warum sie es nicht gemacht haben.
Es ist sehr schwierig, diese Mission so zu machen, wie sie es wollen.
Aber egal.
Was meinst du?
Das war ein cooles Video. Er weiß, wovon er redet. Und die sind nur wirklich nicht gut weggekommen bei ihm.
Das ist der Grund, warum sie die Kartoffel-Ecke isst.
Er ist auch ganz schön bescheuert, sein Ziel hat, einzuschalten, nachdem er schon zwei Minuten beschossen wird.
Der ist cool, der Typ.
Von ihm habe ich schon mal irgendetwas gesehen.
Der kommt mir bekannt vor.
Das Video war cool.
So, jetzt machen wir Kontrast-Programme.
Wir gucken uns jetzt an.
Cobalt in 19 Sekunden.
Nein, nein, die ist Wedge, nicht Ranch.
Wedge.
Wie Kartoffel-Ecke.
Cobalt.
Cobalt in 100 Sekunden.
Kontrast-Programme.
Viel zu leise.
Quik-Maps.
Das stimmt.
So welche haben wir auf der Arbeit auch.
Da will keiner dran.
Es ist so hässlich, es ist so hässlich.
Was?
Moment, sehe ich das richtig?
Der verwendet Wishlist Studio Code für Cobalt.
Es gibt wirklich einen Wishlist Studio Code Support für Cobalt.
Ja, sehe ich das richtig.
Was?
Was ist mit Cobalt los?
So gut.
Huge.
Was haben wir sonst noch so zu bieten?
Alter, war schon zwei Stunden ohne.
Dualsense Joypad.
Juckt mich nicht so.
Jetzt hat Intel noch mehr Probleme.
Why Warcraft 3 Reforged failed.
Weil es Blizzard verschissen hat.
Ah, wir können uns doch neue Battlefield-Top-Plays angucken.
Oder die Top 5 Gerüchte für ein neues Battlefield-Game.
Oder ob teure Mainboards sich lohnen.
Nee, wir gucken Katzen beim Domino spielen.
Das muss man jetzt gucken.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das aufhabe, aber...
Neradon.
Neun Monate.
Huge Sub.
Ich hoffe, ich habe nichts vergessen sonst.
BeatKind sagt Hallo, Hallo BeatKind.
Ich hoffe, ich habe nichts vergessen.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Gut.
Not impressed.
Der Handkerl hat so nach dem Motto geguckt.
Oh Scheiße, ich habe es kaputt gemacht.
Das gibt Ärger.
Guck, war das jetzt eine gute Idee?
War das jetzt eine gute Idee?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich das umschmeißen durfte.
Oh, das müsste ich mal mit meiner machen.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, ich habe keinen Bock so viele Domino-Steine aufzustellen.
Oh, jetzt wird es advanced.
Oh, die sieht aus wie meine erste Katze hier.
Die sieht aus wie original Katze FPS.
Guck mal.
Die sieht auch ein bisschen, naja, ne.
Von den Farben her nicht.
Aber die sieht ja schon echt ähnlich.
Die sieht ja wirklich ähnlich.
Meine wäre da schon längst aufgesprungen, hätte auf den Ball drauf gehauen.
Und jetzt?
Ach, das ist Futter.
Don't PC, vier Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge.
Der will jetzt, dass die Katze das um...
Oder auch nicht.
Das hat so eine, ja, erst mal Dehnungsübung.
Ah.
Das ist advancedes Domino, die Katze muss auch was machen zu.
Was es alles gibt.
Der hat Hunger.
Das hat er bestimmt geübt.
Wahrscheinlich hat er das mit ihm geübt, so nach dem Motto, immer wenn du klingelst, gibt es was zu futtern.
Meine hat schon längst den Ball geschnappt.
Ja, genau.
Die hat sich den Ball da raus...
Das hat meine jetzt auch gemacht.
Die hat wahrscheinlich das ganze Ding umgeschmissen.
Wie lang das wohl gedauert hat aufzustellen?
Ah, jetzt geht es futter.
Das ist so ein...
Sehr nice.
Okay.
Also, wir wollten uns noch mal hier Battlefield Top Plays angucken.
Falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt, ich habe gestern ein ziemlich ähnliches Video gemacht, auch so ungefähr genauso lang oder ähnlich lang, auch mit Battlefield Top Plays.
Gucken wir uns aber aktuelle Battlefield Top Plays an.
Erst mal schönes M16-Metro gespray... Moment, ist das überhaupt ein...
Das ist gar kein M16, oder?
Doch, das ist ein M16.
Aber M16 mit dem Noob-Visier, das Visier spielt man gar nicht. Man spielt das Codra-Visier. Codra-Visier, beste.
Oh, da werden sie weggesprayt.
Aber M16-Metro an der Stelle ist auch dankbar.
Oh, da kriegen sie auch einen Zack. So was hat es nur in Battlefield 3 und 4. So ein ultra krasses Trick. Drum gebäsche.
Und gerade in Battlefield 3, weil die Kugeln so gut durch die Gegner durchgeflogen sind.
Na gut, der piekt die Ecke und ballert immer wieder rein. Ich glaube, das kriegen die meisten von uns auch hin.
Vor allem hat er einen Pfoff des Todes.
Oh, das ist natürlich schon eine f-just streak gewesen. Gibt nix.
Oh, Shotgun. Da wird er geflammt gleich.
Pfft. Ja, gut.
Oh, da liegen so und checken nix. Da liegen so und kapieren nix.
Ähm, Leute, Leute, das Auflegen der Waffe, dieses rübergucken um so eine Mauer, das ging ja erst in Battlefield 4. Das ging in Battlefield 3 noch gar nicht.
Erst mal schönes LMG-Gesprayer.
Hä? Wo war denn jetzt der Sinn von diesem Smoke?
Was ist denn das für eine Waffe? Was ist das für eine Waffe?
Oh, in your face. Get rekt.
Die hat er hart gebashed.
Ich glaube, das ist die Tar, ja. Nur mit Griff und einem komischen Siren.
Was kommt denn jetzt?
Oh nee, der Laser, die weg.
Oh, die Gegner. Komplett kaputt. Die waren wirklich gerade auf dem Klo oder so.
Spaß.
Oh, er wiederbelebt sogar. Dann darf ich den Clip zeigen.
Die Range.
Die Range von der Shotgun, ey.
Und da vorne der Typ, der checkt mal wieder gar nichts.
Er hat mal wieder nichts kapiert.
Spielen alle ohne Audi, ja. Anders kann ich es mir nicht erklären.
Beste Waffe. Das war meine Lieblingswaffe gewesen in dem Game.
Nee, das finde ich überhaupt nicht overpowered. Dazu musste man wenigstens noch was machen.
Kidswitching war das Beste.
Die Ecke ist auch top auf Metro, da können die nicht reingucken.
Oh, hätte klappen können. Ah, es geht noch weiter.
Erst mal auf das Scope zielen.
Kidswitch in Bad Company ging auch übelst ab.
In Bad Company wurde noch durch die Wände retzen kannst mit dem Defi.
Oh, spray sie weg. Alter, jawoll.
Spray sie weg. So muss das sein, als hätte er keine Money mehr.
Pistole. M.
Next, Kid.
Zum Glück hat er eine M16 am Start.
Boah, das hätte noch viel geiler abgehen können.
In Battlefield 5 musst du hoffen, dass der Kidswitch nicht rumbackt.
Okay, ich habe wenig Erfahrung bei Battlefield 5.
Nope.
Das ist heute alles Metro, wie es aussieht. Ja, Metro. Ach, steht er da oben auch.
Die Nachlade-Animationen waren auch cool.
Sponsor-Block, nee. Warum? Wenn wir uns schon Videos von anderen Leuten angucken,
dürfen sie auch sehr laut machen.
Dark Light, das stimmt. Ich glaube, wenn einer einfach ein paar Stunden Metro oder
Noshark Canals oder sowas am Stück spielt, du hast zwangsläufig ein paar gute Clips dabei.
Die Nachlade-Animation von der AN-490 war so geil.
Und die Gegner, komplett planlos, guckt euch an.
Der Jarosz33, da hat er absolut nichts gecheckt.
Du du du du du du du du du du du du.
Jetzt wird er noch mal geschnipesert.
Spielst du selber? Natürlich, natürlich, natürlich spiele ich selber.
Der hatte ganz schön viel.
Gegner heißt Corona, da muss ein aktueller Clip sein.
Was man daran merkt ist, also man kann über Metro sagen, was man will, aber die Wege und
wie die Maps aufgebaut waren, die waren schon durchdacht.
Was sind das eigentlich für Tickets-Anzahlen hier? Geht die Runde 5 Stunden?
Der Red Strain ist stark.
G18, das Ding war auch OP.
Jetzt ist er down.
Das war klar, einmal in den Hof gepasst.
Kaya, ja, spielt er.
P90 hat ja kaum einer gespielt.
Das war ein Zinkstorm.
Ja, mit dem Spotting war es leider nicht möglich, wirklich unentdeckten Metro lang zu gehen,
wenn die Gegner halbwegs kompetent waren, was die hier nicht sind.
Du hast ja für drei Stunden gespottet.
Was ist das?
Was ist da los?
Doch, Huge Skill, Huge Massive Skill.
Ist das Metro?
Haben die Metro Remake?
Ist das Metro, das Slayout ist doch ganz anders.
Naja, wobei, gewisse Ähnlichkeiten hat es.
Es hat schon gewisse Ähnlichkeiten, doch, doch, es hat ein paar Anpassungen, aber...
Aber trotzdem, nicer Clip.
Kann man sich jetzt über das Game streiten, aber das ist ein nicer Clip gewesen.
War das jetzt Battlefield 1 oder 5?
Was wir da gerade gesehen haben, ist das hier.
Ist das 1 oder 5?
Ich erkenne da keinen Unterschied.
Das ist 5.
Woran erkennt man, dass das das 5 ist?
Hat er das jetzt erkannt?
Er hat es gesagt, das ist ja Low-Skill, das kann ja jeder.
Maps an den, ah an den Punkten, ok.
Zeig mal ein paar neue eingesendete Clips.
Ne, jetzt nicht.
Top 5 Rumors for the Next Battlefield Game.
Also mal gucken, was es für neue, für neue Gerüchte, Gerüchte gibt.
Können wir uns das mal angucken.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir da was Neues erfahren werden.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe ja inständig es ist Bad Company 3 und dann von einem Entwicklerteam,
was irgendwie ein bisschen Plan hat und weiß, wie man ein gutes Bad Company macht.
Die können aber auch meinetwegen ruhig einen Battlefield 6 machen.
Wie es heißt, ist mir eigentlich, mittlerweile ist es eh egal, wie die Dinger heißen.
Es ist immer noch so hängen geblieben, dass Battlefield 1 vor Battlefield 5 kommt.
Und wer sich das ausgedacht hat, alles, den musst du schlagen, der ist so dämlich.
Warum mussten sie das Battlefield 1 nennen?
Hätten sie das nicht Battlefield 1916 nennen können oder so?
Naja.
Also die Premium-Variante, ich finde es gar nicht so schlecht, wie sie das machen,
außer dass mir das Game nicht gefällt.
Damals bei Battlefield 3 hätte ich mir gewünscht, dass Battlefield 3 ein Service Game ist,
ohne zu wissen, dass es sich Service Game nennt, weil damals hat man das ja noch nicht gemacht.
Auf jeden Fall eine ordentliche Custom-Server wieder, bitte.
Dass man auch mal ein Sniper-Limit machen kann.
Das war ja teilweise public, weil Battlefield 3 und 4 kaum zu spielen,
wenn irgendwie das ganze Team da meint, oh, geiles Sniper am Arsch der Welt,
bei dem aber ein Pig im Spawn liegen.
Oh man, die Leute.
Macht Vordafone wieder Scheiße, kann ich dir sagen.
Vordafone macht Scheiße.
Hat gerade geleckt.
Oh, please.
Ich glaube denen sogar, dass Battlefield Bad Company 3 in Entwicklung war.
Das kann ich mir sogar gut vorstellen, aber ob das natürlich jemals rauskommt,
ob sie das fertig verfolgen, das ist was anderes.
Dass sie das auf jeden Fall probieren werden oder probiert haben, intern zumindest,
finde ich liegt auf der Hand.
Das war ja auch sehr erfolgreich, also warum nicht?
Ja, das habe ich auch gelesen, dass sie nicht wissen, was das gut gemacht hat,
aber das ist Blödsinn.
Das ist einfach Bullshit, was sie da erzählt haben.
Ich meine, sie wären auch in der Lage zu sein, sie können ja sonst auch alles drum herum analysieren,
da werden sie doch wohl ihre eigenen Games analysieren können,
warum sie die Leute gemocht haben.
Im Zweifelfall sollen sie einfach mal ein paar Leute fragen, die es gespielt haben.
Also das halte ich für eine merkwürdige Ausrede.
Was ist denn das für eine Map?
Ist das Flat Zone? Nee, was ist das?
China DLC? Ah.
Pearl Market, okay, habe ich noch nicht gespielt.
Mir ist es eigentlich egal, wie es heißt.
Wow, der Panzer.
Der flitzt aber ganz schön, der Panzer.
Bam, sehr neuer Treffer.
Ja gut, ein ordentliches Singleplayer wäre nicht verkehrt.
Man muss aber halt sagen, ich fand den Battlefield 4 Singleplayer schrecklich
und Battlefield 3 war okay.
Macht einfach ein gescheites Battlefield.
Eigentlich ist es mir fast egal, was ihr macht, hauptsache ihr macht ein gescheites Battlefield.
Ich will kein Remake von irgendwas, kein Remake, ich will ein neues, ordentliches Battlefield.
Dass sie gute Maps mit reinnehmen aus alten Games habe ich keine Probleme mit, gibt ja genug Content.
Find ich nicht gut. Battlefield 3 hat es am besten gemacht, fand ich.
In Battlefield 3 konntest du Häuser nicht kaputt machen mit Treppen.
In Bad Company 1 konntest du auch stragende Strukturen nicht kaputt machen.
In Bad Company 2 konntest du ein bisschen viel teilweise kaputt machen.
Wenn du dir mal Oasis oder sowas anguckst, da steht ja nichts mehr, da ist ja nur noch Matsch nach ein paar Minuten.
Battlefield 3 hat es am besten gemacht.
Das macht erinnernd an,
Das könnte sein, aber das hatten wir doch schon zweimal.
Vietnam hatten wir doch schon, wir hatten in Bad Company 2 Vietnam und wir hatten ein eigenes Vietnam Battlefield.
Historisch würde es Sinn machen, für DICE die Progression durch die Historiebücher weiterzuführen.
Schauen wir uns an die großen und ikonischen Waffen an.
Wir haben Battlefield 1 in World War 1 gesehen, Battlefield 5 in World War 2.
Die könnten auch ohne Probleme irgendwas machen, was so Pan 80 angesiedelt wäre.
Es gibt so unendlich viele Möglichkeiten.
Wichtig ist, dass der Inhalt taugt. Und da habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Es wurde schon gemacht und die Franchise hat es natürlich gesehen, Battlefield Vietnam liebte es.
Viele Leute wollen es wiederholen und es wäre sehr populär zwischen bestimmten Fans.
In der heutigen Zeit, in der alle von allem verletzt werden, wäre es eine witzige Idee,
ein Spiel zu konzentrieren auf einen gruseligen und kontroversiellen Konflikt wie Vietnam.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Heute sind wir ja bei allem verletzt.
Ist Vodafone wieder im Rumspacken?
Ach komm, Vodafone, please.
Was ist hier los?
Es laggt.
Okay, ich glaube, das hat sich erledigt.
Vodafone möchte nicht, dass wir weiter gucken.
WireGuard-Tunnel einrichten.
Ja, wohin denn?
Und vor allem hoffen, dass das Routing zu dem Endpunkt besser ist.
Ja, Leute, es laggt. Was soll ich machen?
Na, hat es sich wieder eingekriegt?
Wäre mir interessant zu wissen, woran das liegt. Na ja, an meinem WLAN oder was sonst?
Das liegt daran, weil die Anbindung von Unity Media in ihrem RZ oder wo auch immer ich rauskomme wahrscheinlich so scheiße ist.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass es wirklich an dem Anschluss zwischen mir und Unity Media liegt,
sondern dass das Peering oder was auch immer bei Unity Media einfach sackt.
Echt? 20 Jahre?
Echt? 20 Jahre, gegen was?
Man könnte auch durchaus ein bisschen unbekannte Konflikte mal machen.
Ah, das brauche ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so.
Ja, vor der Eiszeit sind wir noch ein bisschen entfernt.
Ja, da hat er Recht. Da hat er Recht. Das muss einfach Inhalt nicht taugen.
Leider ist Battlefield 5 so ein Game, das die irgendwie ewig supporten.
Ich will Neues, was es taugt oder was mir gefällt.
Garantiert kriegen wir eine neue Battlefield. Dafür steckt da immer noch zu viel Kohle drin.
Juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Ja, Blablabla, sonst Kram erzählen die immer.
Ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass auf den neuen Konsolen auch nochmal Battlefield 5 rauskommt.
Jaja, denke ich auch.
Eigentlich will ich einfach nur, dass das Gameplay was traugt. Rest ist mir egal. Hauptsache das Gameplay ist wieder was, was mir gefällt.
Und ich hätte auch kein Problem mit, wenn es weniger schreiende Grills gäbe im Multiplayer.
Das wäre auch noch so ein Punkt, da hätte ich nichts gegen.
Darf man ja, da muss man aufpassen, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ich meine damit nicht Mädels, die spielen in dem Voice Chat rumschreien, sondern ich meine die Ingame Voice Samples der World War 2 Mädels, die rumschreien.
Das muss nicht sein.
Ich hoffe, es kommt mal wieder ein gescheites Battlefield, aber wir werden da bestimmt noch 1-2 Jahre drauf warten müssen, dass es überhaupt angekündigt wird, wohlgemerkt.
Ich glaube, die Probleme hängen mit der Engine zusammen. Nee, glaube ich nicht.
Die Armee hat das Problem, dass sie mittlerweile Frostbite für jeden Scheiß verwenden, wo es überhaupt nicht für gedacht war.
Wenn du dann schon hörst, dass die Need for Speed, dass es funktioniert, die Autos irgendwelche versteckten Waffen haben müssen und sowas.
Mein gut, Tricks und komische Hex brauchste bei allem, ja.
Das Problem ist, dass ja vom eigentlichen Dice, die die richtig guten Teile gemacht haben, irgendwie nichts mehr da ist.
Die haben sich ja alle verpisst.
Ja, Trion 93, das ist auch so eine Sache, was mir absolut nicht einleuchtet.
Wenn man sich das Menü aus Battlefield 3 oder 4 anguckt, das hat gut funktioniert, aber auf einmal ist es Engine Limitation.
Was ich auch nicht schlecht finden würde, würden wir ein neues Battlefield bekommen, nicht von Dice und nicht von EA.
Aber sagen wir mal so, das heißt dann natürlich nicht Battlefield, sondern irgendwie halt ein Battlefield, was nicht Battlefield heißt, aber halt das bessere Battlefield ist.
Wäre nicht das erste Mal, dass sowas passiert.
Aber die, die es probiert haben, sind bisher ziemlich gescheiter da dran.
Den letzten, die es probiert haben, war diese World War 3 Geschichte, aber ich glaube, die haben es auch verschissen. Spielt das jemand?
Das hier.
Die haben es irgendwie verkackt, wenn man sich das bei den Steam Stats anguckt.
Der Ground War Modus ist für ein Arsch. Ja, hier haben sie es irgendwie verkackt, die hatten durchaus die Chance.
Ho, 28 Leute spielen. Nui. Wahnsinn. Ganze 28 Leute. Unglaublich.
Das ist ja wie Artifakt. Stimmt, spielt das noch jemand?
Hahaha. Fuck, Alter. Boah.
Oh, die haben es verschissen.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass es so schlimm ist.
Moment, ist es das überhaupt? Ist das das überhaupt? Ja, oder? Ich kenne das Logo gar nicht.
Boah, krass. Boah, hat das abgekackt. Hyper abgekackt hat das.
Aber letzten 30 Tage plus 43 Prozent. Ja, aber ich meine, in welchem Maßstab reden wir hier?
Wie viel spielen das? Ah, yes. Exzellent. Ja, das ist klar, dass es nicht so viele spielen.
Jetzt haben wir nicht so viele in der VR-Brille. Ich bin, ja, Tribulon, es ist genau das Gleiche bei mir.
Ich würde es echt unglaublich gerne spielen, so als alter Half-Life Fan.
Aber ich will mir nicht für ein Spiel eine VR-Brille kaufen. Ich meine, was soll ich sonst mit der VR-Brille machen?
Das Einzige, was du sonst noch machen kannst, wäre VR-Porn gucken. Aber ansonsten außer das Spiel will ich nicht spielen.
Es gibt doch einen Non-VR-Mod. Nee, ohne VR ist das nichts.
Was Tommy schreibt, hat mir ein bei Grover geliehen. Was ist Grover? Grover habe ich noch nie gehört.
Was ist Grover? Das Neueste aus der Welt hat richtig Flexibelmieten. Aha.
Ah, da kann man sich Zeugs... Achso. Ja, die Idee ist doch eigentlich gar nicht schlecht. Was kostet das da so?
Also mal angenommen, was holt man sich da so? Eine HTC oder was ist denn so eine gute 3D-Brille?
VR. Oh, ich habe Grover kaputt gemacht.
Also die Oculus haben sie, haben sie auch irgendwie. Haben sie auch? Index? Nee, haben sie nicht.
Ok, angenommen, was kostet der Kram jetzt? Ok, was kostet sowas hier?
35 Euro im Monat. Was kostet es neu?
450. Ja, zum Ausprobieren ist es doch nicht schlecht und wie lange muss man das? Mindestmietdauer? Ah, Verstehe.
Exzellent. Ich muss schon mal 70 Euro bezahlen, wenn ich es dann in einem Monat ausprobieren will.
Interessant. Von der Plattform habe ich noch nie was gehört, ehrlich gesagt.
Ok, der erste Monat ist 50%, ok. Ja, vielleicht sollte ich mir doch mal eine 3D-Brille holen.
Was? HTC? Was war das? Index? Nee. Was war? Warum Index? Was ist? What the fuck?
Fall für Index.
Das ist ordentlich. Ein Schnapper. Aber auch bleibst dabei. Ja, muss ich mir mal schlau machen.
Vielleicht hole ich mir doch eine. Was zum Teufel ist das hier?
Cybershoes. Walking in VR-Games. Warum ist er da auf der Bühne und bei ihm gucken die Leute zu?
Mega spannend. Ist echt spannend so ein Dude da zu sehen. Er spielt gerade einen VR-Porn.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was das für einer sein sollte bei der Pose.
Ok, ok. Hör auf. Klappe.
Das andere kann ich mir aber nicht vorstellen.
Das ist auch super, die an die Wand zu hängen. Also wenn man sich nicht für seinen VR-Headset kauft, dann für am an die Wand zu hängen.
Excellent. Was ist das?
Was zum Teufel guck ich mir da an?
Gibt es in diesem Game noch was anderes als über diesen Mini-Teich hüpfen?
Die Musik dabei.
Wie der eine jetzt aufgestanden ist. Ho war das anstrengend.
Was wenn ich alles empfohlen kriege?
Ich glaube ich gehe jetzt was essen und mal aufs Klo.
Oh Gott, das kann ich mir nicht anhören.
Das beste Gaming-Headset ist nicht wireless.
Linus Drop-Tips?
Was zum Teufel?
Das tut ja schon richtig weh beim Zugucken.
Was war denn das?
Autsch. Direkt.
Das kriegt man wieder zusammen. Kein Ding, sei es nicht viel kaputt.
Easy-Killer, ich habe gehört bei Hardware-Rats suchen sie noch PC-Schrauber.
Gleich fällt es runter.
Das ist schlecht.
Warum werfen die eigentlich mit ihren Handys rum?
Das kann man auch nur machen, wenn man genug Handys kaputt gemacht hat.